okay
being 10 o'clock Apple time
we will open the
budget work session for the community
colleges when we welcome Chancellor
Rubenstein and director Reed
good morning and thank you for having us
back I assume this is the opportunity
now that the governor's budget is out
for us to get into a little bit more
detail uh once again you have a
presentation in front of you and this
time I'm going to try and do a little
bit better job of staying with script
but we'll certainly be here more to
answer questions that the committee has
so appreciate your time this morning
as a second slide illustrates our
service to the state as Educators is a
Statewide mission
campuses placed in regions throughout
New Hampshire
93 percent of our students are New
Hampshire residents and the information
we have suggests that most of them work
and persist after graduation in the
communities where they live so the the
education they receive continues to
resonate for New Hampshire
our programs include our dual enrollment
in high schools more than 100 high
schools participate in running start but
we also have Early College Programs we
host a couple of charter school programs
on our campuses
our core work is reflected in associate
degree and certificate programs the
associate degrees being in some cases
career focused and Automotive for
instance and Welding in other cases
leading to transfer Pathways University
system and other four-year institutions
and then we also increasingly have been
doing more with career focus training
not what's currently non-credit
programming intended to help people
already in the workforce or entering the
workforce shorter time frame more more
immediate access and impact for their
personal circumstances and for their
employers
when we put together our budget request
for the governor we had a core set of
priorities one has to do with our
long-term mission of supporting access
to post-secondary education through
affordability uh reflected in the
programs that we do in high schools but
also the pathways to the community
college system and then through the
community college system to the
university system and beyond
we're continuing to focus on
strengthening New Hampshire's Workforce
and increasingly want to find ways that
our physical resources our campuses
across the state can serve as uh
resources for their communities beyond
the following slide it's page four is
our current appropriation the three
percent efficiency and the specific in
the fiscal 23 budget the specific
scholarship support for dual enrollment
concurrent enrollment courses
specifically scholarships for stem and
CTE courses
building on that we made some very
particular requests of the governor
we asked that the state allow us to
continue to freeze tuition we've kept
tuition virtually flat for the last 12
years it was 210 dollars a credit in
2011. it's 215 dollars a credit today
and our goal was to keep that flat in
part because we're allowing uh
affordability to catch up with us if you
will
we're in a position now where the value
of federal Pell Grant now exceeds the
cost of full-time enrollment for a New
Hampshire resident in the coming year
that's a threshold that wouldn't have
been true 10 years ago or five years ago
and if we had simply allowed tuition to
increase over time with the rate of
inflation it still wouldn't be true so
the combination of State support and and
fiscal discipline we've we've reached an
important milestone for the state
we asked specifically for support for
Workforce programs these are typically
short-term programs not currently
eligible for federal financial aid
over the last several years there have
been competing bills in Congress the U.S
Congress that have not gotten through
the jobs act and more recently uh
piece of legislation with the acronym
Pell intended to support lifelong
learning either of those would help
address this issue which is creating Aid
to support short-term programs with a
work for Workforce Focus but in the
absence of that kind of support for a
lot of Learners this is what they need
not a semester not a credit based not a
degree based learning opportunity maybe
it's a certificate in lean Six Sigma
maybe it's a CDL program but on a
different calendar than a semester-based
program like the one we have at White
Mountains Community College
so that was a second request
we asked for support to expand access to
our early childhood education programs
because we think we're in a position to
make a contribution to the state's need
for more high quality accessible
affordable child care and we think that
this would contribute to expanding the
pathway in the pipeline increase the
availability of affordable child care in
the state
we ask for support for the Dual and
concurrent enrollment program as I
described earlier currently it's a
million and a half in scholarship
support and it's specifically stem and
CTE courses we wanted to expand that to
up to five courses a year and Beyond
just stem and CTE courses and as I
described when I was here last time in
some ways dual enrollment is our primary
contribution to affordability for middle
class families who are not going to be
eligible for federal grants for
post-secondary but if we can assist them
in more more affordable access to
completing a path to college while still
in high school we can help manage the
the longer term costs help them avoid
debt
we did ask for sufficient funds at the
time what we thought would be required
to bring a promise program effectively
covering the cost of community college
for students who had high need
we've subsequently refined the estimate
of what that would take and then we'd
ask for some support for Energy
Efficiency projects as I mentioned we've
got campuses across the state a growing
part of our expense has been utilities
and thinking long term trying to
mitigate those costs with renewable
alternatives
so with the governor's budget first let
me say we're grateful that was um we
appreciate the support in addition to
the the foundation of three percent from
the efficiency budget support sufficient
to allow us to keep tuition Frozen for
the biennium and specific investment in
that early childhood education we we
greatly appreciated although I don't
know that we've seen it my understanding
is House Bill 2 also has an increased
additional half a million dollars to
support dual and concurrent enrollment
and give us a little bit more latitude
because part of what we currently have
is scholarships to continue to deliver
running start in high schools in some
schools they may not have the teachers
who are academically qualified to
deliver parts of the curriculum for us
to have more ability to be creative in
deploying our faculty to support that
instruction can expand opportunities for
students beyond the scholarship
um
we'd also ask for and in the language we
understand uh Board of Trustees would
have authority to address the
participation of future employees not
current and not currently employed and
eligible but future employees not
otherwise eligible to participate in the
state Employee Retirement System this is
a long-term uh issue for managing
expense when the universe community
college system became an independent
entity in 2007 property transferred to
the Board of Trustees in 2011 but no
change was made in participation in the
state Employee Retirement System we
currently have some employees in a
separate 403 b plan majority of our
employees are still in the state
Employee Retirement System and it's an
area where expense continues to grow and
over which the board has no Authority so
we had requested the board have that
authority to make a decision not to make
the decision but the authority when they
made the when the time came that they
um
as you can see at the bottom of Slide
Five
several of the items that we requested
were not part of the funding from the
governor's budget and certainly
understand competing pressures and
priorities
among those and and perhaps really
absent from them
we were a little bit surprised and to
see no Capital funding for the community
college system in the next biennium
proposed we weren't necessarily looking
for
[Music]
on slide six we weren't necessarily
looking for uh new buildings but we have
appreciated the support we've had for
critical maintenance needs for I.T in
particular in recent years and and so
had anticipated there'd be some coverage
for that
among the things that we had
specifically asked for and for which
funding wasn't allocated we still
believe that absent Federal funding in
either the jobs act or the Pell Bill in
Congress that funding for Workforce
programs will help particularly working
adults looking to upskill for different
Industries or change careers into
different industries that are vital to
um
just some notes
as I mentioned earlier about the
affordability part of that has been the
state's continued support for our work
part of it has been our efforts to
manage our own expenses
we've reduced our Workforce by 30
percent primarily by attrition as
attrition has occurred reorganizing how
we do that work to be able to maintain
services and deliver our programs in a
more efficient way
we continue to look at ways to identify
services that can be centralized we're
currently working on some of that with
it
looking at shared positions Regional
positions within the system again just
capitalizing on the efficiency and the
talent that we have to deploy more
effectively
one other note about our programs I
think I touched upon this in in previous
discussion
as our portfolio of academic programs
has shifted one of the things that's
most clear is that the place where we
continue to have a critical role are
programs that are
in healthcare whether it's nursing
dental hygiene
welding automotive technology
engineering technologies that do not
have Alternatives within the state those
programs also tend to be some of the
most expensive that we deliver and as
our enrollments are increasingly
concentrated in that area
it's it becomes one of the balance
points as we try and maintain
affordability but ensure the quality of
those programs and although we're not
making a specific ask it's simply
helpful I think for you to understand
that that's part of the dynamic that we
we work with to sustain programs that
are significantly more costly to deliver
that that simply don't have Alternatives
in the state
foreign
happy to stop if questions have come up
but we've reached a familiar slide this
is reinforcing the point that I made had
we simply allowed tuition to rise at the
rate of consumer inflation not even
higher education inflation which is
notoriously more fast-paced than
consumer inflation but it at the
consumer rate uh tuition would be close
to 280 a credit
we've kept it virtually flat for 12
years that that increases the buying
and
to the extent that it's helpful on slide
nine an overview of our
revenue and allocation of our expenses
these are both for fiscal 23.
just for context the total figure on
Revenue about 124 million total figure
and I think at this point I'll stop and
entertain any questions the committee
has
thank you thank you Mr chairman I I have
two questions well first of all since
you're talking about your revenues and
expenses
um
do you have a ballpark figure about what
for the unmet needs
to be added that would have to be added
to
what's in the in the governor's budget
here yeah if if we were going to try and
deliver a promise program for New
Hampshire residents who are Pell
eligible those students from the federal
government judges have be eligible for
that Grant to pick up the balance of
what they don't cover this would be for
students who don't have a zero
contribution but then something larger
best estimate would be about three and a
half million dollars so roughly half of
what we had originally been looking at
and part of that is that the value of
the Pell Grant projected for next year
has increased thank you
um I follow up I want to thank you both
for putting me in touch with President
Lloyd and White Mountains Community
College and and when I did speak with
him last week he was just getting ready
to make a presentation to the local
school board instead of instead of
um keeping the the North Conway office
open they're going to close that and
blend everything into the high school
program can can you just give me any
little more specifics on what will be
included in the high school
so I I I won't be able to go into
complete depth on that one and I didn't
mean to be uh vague when we last met but
I knew that he president Lloyd wanted to
have that conversation with his
Community First
current facility is a lease facility
yeah and relatively low it uh activity
So the plan I believe is primarily
related to
um biological sciences and they're going
to partner with the high school to make
the programs that much more accessible
in the same way that we're looking for
ways to make our campuses more engaged
this is just turning the coin the other
way and capitalizing on the relationship
we have with the high school so
most of the programs currently offered
at that location in Conway will continue
to be available but not all of them and
part of that's a function of demand yes
thank you it sounded like a sensible
plan and and to um
to have the to in order to have more
people take advantage of it by putting
it in high school instead of having to
be a whole separate
program we are trying to remove those
kinds of barriers for students and to
the extent that students are accustomed
to learning in their High School
environment and capitalize on that
relationship we can we can do better and
simply a better use of resources for us
but also to put that facility that
wasn't getting a lot of activity to
better use for that community that least
facility can probably serve some private
business better than it was able to
serve us
thank you I appreciate that and that's
that's really what what I was asking you
last week but was it's long to how to
get local people to take take advantage
of the programs more more advantage of
it than they were
um
when I look at the things that were not
funded it seems to me that uh you've got
apples and bananas going on here because
uh Energy Efficiency or like one-time
Investments but the trouble with the
budget process is if that is a budget
line then that becomes a budget budgeted
item ah nausea you know I mean it
doesn't it doesn't go away
so
I'm just observing I'm not criticizing
yeah that that's entirely true um in his
budget address the governor did note
that he was using
um the surplus funds to fund one-time
projects and the energy improvement work
that would be a one time that would not
be in addition to base that would
continue indefinitely similarly on side
six we outline a most significant unmet
need in the Capital Area and the
governor had also indicated that he used
in his budget formulation he used some
Surplus dollars to fund those kind of
one-time capital projects we have not
seen House Bill 2 to know what
specifically is funded that way in it
with fy23 surplus funds but we are
hoping that that the committee may see
some room there to make adjustments to
help us meet these Capital needs
particularly for critical maintenance
and I.T infrastructure upgrades which
again would not go to base those would
be one time
runs for FY 24 and 25
but it would seem that you could also
use one-time funds for buying equipment
that lasts more than five years or you
know
I'm just saying it's going to push the
right I I think we're we're trying we're
trying to be respectful of the process
and not overreach even our request for
the promise program that eight million
dollars which was uh our best estimate
at the time we felt a little bit of of
angst about that so I think we're just
trying to be respectful of competing
priorities
so what would your total one-time
our Capital request had been had been
quite High
um initially we had outlined almost 20
million dollars worth of capital
projects and and none of that was
included
we have been reassessing what our kind
of most most critical priorities are in
the capital realm and it's frankly it's
critical maintenance of our facilities
we have seven colleges across the state
many of them were built in the 1960s
these require just ongoing kind of
attention and specific projects like
um rooftop units and boilers and roofs
and some energy efficient
upgrades such as Windows as outlined on
slide six we have kind of trimmed that
to a six million dollar
The Six Million Dollar ask for that work
you can see that in the first bullet
point
is that per year or for by any of that
question wouldn't the Solar projects for
Energy Efficiency fall in the same uh
category that chairman Emerick was
asking about yes they would so now we
are looking at you know 15-6 for the
critical maintenance and the nine
requested for efficiency
yes the six for critical maintenance is
really
um critical And Timely right the the
Solar projects are something that we
would we would we would really love to
be able to do
um because that it would help not just
our campuses
um address utility costs but it would it
would have broader effects on on energy
use in our in our regions right if we
were to if we were able to mount solar
arrays that could generate a lot of
energy then that would reduce demand for
other types of energy generation quick
follow-up
do you have an estimate of the you know
savings that you will achieve by
investing the 9 million in solar energy
obviously it's hard to predict
electricity prices I I'll grant you that
but and we cannot assume that at the
current levels but do you have you know
uh expectation that your operational
costs will be reduced by a certain
sorry Scott Fields Chief Operating
Officer we've estimated with the new
energy contract that we've just signed
if we could do the solar array we would
produce roughly 50 to 60 percent of our
energy consumption
utility bills planned for this year over
three million dollars so over time that
would pay off in 45 years so if I
understand correctly or saying about
half of your bill would be cut so we are
looking at one to one point five million
at the current rates which again change
well we've locked into a contract for
the current rate so that would be right
and fairly static what's the life
expectation of the solar panels I'm
sorry what's the life expectancy of the
solar panels we did preliminary research
and it was
I have to go back and double check but
it's at least 15.
and one last clarification
um actually I lost my train of thought I
yield
thank you is this for all campuses or
um just a concern of mine
um
enrollment you have a number of
facilities they
used to full capacity
um is there I think what you're doing in
Conway is a great idea
um I hate to see a lot of money invested
in facilities that might end up on a for
sale
at some future date so where are you in
terms of your enrollment and how
based on that what are the real needs in
terms of your actual structures
so you're correct the long-term trend
for physical enrollment in our campuses
has been down part of what we're looking
at is how do we make our campuses more
accessible for other purposes
find Partners whose work is compatible
with ours and that will bring more value
and more activity more activity of the
camps more value to the community as an
example in Littleton another part of
White Mountains Community College
there's a Head Start program and a New
Hampshire employment security office on
that campus we're looking for similar
Partnerships that bring value to the
state and to the communities that we
serve by co-locating those kinds of
offices so we don't Envision giving up
the campuses we have we're trying to
revitalize them to make them more useful
more more impactful in those ways if I
could just add um in our original
capital request which we developed
almost a year ago the timetable of the
state capital budget process goes back
that far we had some requests in there
that was that related to specific
buildings and um Renovations those are
not in what you see before you today in
part for that very reason we are in a
process of kind of reimagining how we're
going to be using our space given
um a greater shift to online education
given you know a number of different
factors so we're not attempting to kind
of bring those those projects forward
right now what we're focusing on right
now are keeping our buildings
basically sound
Joe
thank you Mr chairman oh thank you for
being here again uh one question I asked
a dumb question what's Esso New
Hampshire
or s-o-n-h
oh I'm sorry that's that's probably too
obvious
um yeah uh you got some other questions
too is there any uh talk of combining
CTE with uh Community call system
because we're I mean we're heading in
that direction but uh that that would
seem to be an all logical move because
like like welding once you know welding
even in high school it'll you know it it
goes right into the community call
system I mean you once once you know how
to weld you know how to weld well I know
commissioner edelblue has talked about
some potential joint facilities in the
future that would would be an efficient
use of resources and recently we've
spoken and on behalf of nhti have spoken
with the Concord Regional Technical
Center about the possibility of
co-location and collaboration around
specifically their program so the
opportunities are there and some of that
is already happening I expect we'll see
more of it over time
like uh follow-up
um capital reserve funds in in this
school districts we use capital reserve
funds because you don't replace a roof
every year I mean you're going to have
several roofs in the in the future can
you use Capital do we have a system in
the state to
you know put money away for for those uh
timely uh
endeavors
but we we we do have reserves yes
um specific to Capital
Capital Reserves
or general reserves General reserves are
thank you
everything so it's not earmarked as
capital reserves it's it's a broader
bucket
thank you Mr chairman so I remembered
what my last question on the electricity
was how what's the duration of the fixed
rate contract you're currently in
five years I'll repeat the answer so we
don't have to move people around and I
would really appreciate it I don't know
if I missed that I'm looking on slide
four in the bottom table there is a
freeze tuition for the next two years
and the tuition reset to bring down the
cost of Education I understand the free
situation but I'm not sure I understand
the tuition reset line
so the the original proposal when we
were trying to figure out how we could
bring a promise program what's sometimes
called that I got it thank you sorry the
the wording didn't
thank you
what what are the qualifications for
someone that teaches in a community
called system and you know like like a
welder does he you have to have a degree
or or just have the knowledge to uh to
teach yeah typically there's a
requirement for uh and pay on discipline
to be a master's degree or above in the
discipline in the case of specialized
knowledge Automotive or welding it's
going to be more industry certifications
but also with experience teaching some
thank you um
as you know I did that for a living for
about a decade in the it field you know
it was exactly that process and for the
record when I got hired some of the
training centers universities actually
ask you to you know present in front of
their audience to determine whether you
can teach not only whether you can
Master the topic so while requirements
may vary they are generally very
effective in determining who's going to
do a good job
um so you know those are the type of
programs I think are very beneficial
do you have any statistics in terms of
what's the impact you know the positive
impact on the people that take them you
know are you looking at their you know
do they get better job opportunities do
they get a raise is there any kind of
outcome you know information
to help explain why those Investments
really pay off for the taxpayers
right I I wish I could give you us uh
specific set of Statistics I think when
we spoke the first time as a when we
joined the committee I mentioned for
instance 34 3200 nurses registered
nurses prepared by the community college
system over the last 12 years
at least four and we're waiting for the
data on the fifth year to see if New
Hampshire continues to have the highest
national pass rate on NCLEX licensure so
you know whether it's Automotive we can
go field by field and we've prepared
roughly a thousand welders with
certifications and advanced
certifications over the last 12 years as
well we can go career area by career
area and look at the earnings for people
in those fields and demonstrate that
value but I don't have a concise chart
that I can point to if just as a quick
follow-up obviously you know it would be
very useful if even something brief
could be prepared and shared with us
because it's good to be able to show the
return on that investment to be able to
justify an investment and you know it
would be very useful thank you thank you
thinking uh Shipyard do you work with
them uh you know to further there
because it is a lot of use for what you
what you teach from from a number of
years Great Bay Community College has
had a partnership with a port safe
Portsmouth Naval Shipyard
and does that I mean do you do you work
concurrently or do you do you teach and
then or do they get in your program and
then because they they have a they have
an apprenticeship program of their own
you you work within that program
we I guess I would say it's parallel
it's not their apprenticeship program
but we provide education professional
I'm just going to talk about two
universes that are starting to cross
uh you're talking about facility
utilization
if you go to Health and Human Services
I know that the developmentally disabled
Community has seven regions uh
distributed around the state uh and and
they're they're have developed Mental
Health
emergency units that go out into the
areas
so my thought process and this is where
the two universes cross is get together
with whoever it is in health and human
services that needs locations
and you may you may find you know a new
tenant
we are having conversations our
Rochester uh facilities currently
hosting career counselors from DHHS for
instance those are the kinds of
Partnerships that we think are helpful
for us to establish and we'll continue
to explore those
foreign
thank you um can you talk a little bit
about
um expand Workforce credential programs
I think that that and could you relate
that to would that be income driving for
your programs
they they would be currently most of our
Workforce uh related programs are Break
Even roughly
well
um
medical assisting
yeah l and a type programs but also
um
trying to think of some of the other uh
exams do a lot of training on things
like Excel basically off you know office
tools for people already in the
workforce
um but almost anything we currently do
on a credit basis and I'll offer the
example earlier we currently offer a CDL
program as a credit based program
through White Mountains Community
College that could be turned into a
non-credit Workforce program with a more
concise timeline to allow people to be
up and running more quickly
just as a follow-up actually to build on
what you were asking about our mental
health centers are really struggling
um do you offer programs
um that would produce workers I the
whole problem is we have a shortage of
Workforce quite frankly but in Preparing
People to work in the field of mental
health because that's really an area
that's problematic right now we we do we
have a certified community support
workers we have
programs with substance misuse and
recovery programs along those lines and
again we also have the potential to
build programs that would align with
those needs particularly for Frontline
workers
so that potential would cost 1.5 million
well
we thought that was a reasonable
investment to request to allow us to
begin to scale those kinds of programs
it's potentially a limitless opportunity
but we are trying to make sure that we
could do it in a in a in a way that
reflected quality and and allowed us to
focus on what we could do well
start
um I
I believe it's it's a way to get a
pathway to your programs
um and it's really cost effective for
our students in terms of reducing the
four-year cost of their education
um so by increasing
what how many more students would you be
able to offer scholarships to with the
3.25 of the pre
3.25 million well in a typical Year
we're serving about 8 000 students
through that program
the increase in funding that we're
looking at potentially an additional two
to four thousand students they want to
qualify because part of the way this is
structured is that students could take
more classes so it may not be
two to four thousand more students it
may be one or two thousand more students
but those students having opportunity at
least some of them to take more courses
than they currently have and the cost
continues at 150 for those choosing to
um two quick questions I missed
something around the Board of Trustees
and the retirement plans they have
authority to make decisions what
decision
well
and presently in statute that's
something that has to be negotiated
whether or not uh the
employees represented by collective
bargaining agreements will choose an
alternative plan for our staff who are
represented by the sca they several
years ago introduced that as an option
that they can choose either this state
Employee Retirement System or a program
administered by a private provider a 403
b plan for our full-time faculty there's
no option and the only option is the the
state Employee Retirement System this
would give the Board of Trustees the
authority to make a decision that that
is an option
what's the option that's just an
alternative plan to the state Employee
Retirement System so it's offering The
Faculty an alternative plan okay or I I
want to be clear I haven't seen the
precise language but if if it falls it
could be the board would have the
authority to make a decision that after
a certain date newly hired employees
would have only that alternative option
and I think the university system opted
out of the state plan
two two years ago three years ago so I I
I I I don't know that the university
system has been in that plan if ever
certainly for decades okay I I I was in
division one before and there was some
of this in hb2 having to do with UNH and
I can't remember what the machinations
were all about but I I
doesn't matter now the the old
I I can I can think of one element that
would have come up but I don't know that
it's Jermaine
foreign
I always think I ask this some of the
areas in which you train people which
are critical you know the Early
Childhood the nursing they're still
underpaid and it's a blessing to them
that they have an alternative to go with
you as opposed to I always go back to
the Dartmouth student who all she wanted
to do was teach Pilates and ended up
with you know 160 000 of debt
um
what can you do as advocates for
increasing salary ranges or you know
what can you do to help these students
that you're training to go into
basically what I still consider to be
low-income jobs
um I'll be honest say there may be
limits on what we can do but what we're
trying to do is manage the pieces we can
control if we can help people get the
foundation that they need to pursue the
career they care about without incurring
the expense or the debt that accompanies
it we're at least creating the
opportunity that for the subsequent
education they may need to progress in
that field that they're not saddled with
with the earlier debt that that may be a
barrier so our efforts are to try and
enable as much forward motion as we can
within our scope of ability thank you
I may shed a bit more light on this
situation I worked when I worked you
know taught those classes I worked for
both private employed training centers
and public universities that had these
types of programs
none of them had to directly advocate
for their graduates to get higher wages
because what they did in improving their
skills made them significantly more
valuable and frankly you know that may
lead to people going out of state to get
a higher paid job but people who are
highly skilled have access to you know
better jobs without the need for the
entity who trains them to take care of
that but by giving them the skills we
are empowering them to negotiate and get
into the right situation for themselves
and I think that's a highly valuable you
know effort and I think doing that makes
much more difference than you would
possibly make by you know lobbying for
um
how much land do you have or
the ability to expand
I I really uh I want to comment on the
uh Great Bay use of uh the old uh
buildings on the mall and uh on the on
the Milton Road I mean that's a great
repurpose of uh and it and it fits
almost perfectly with with the high
school you know Spalding High School in
Rochester I mean that's that's that's
brilliant as far as I'm concerned but uh
how much other you know how much other
properties and going along with uh
chairman emmerich here uh you know some
of these could be repurp you know you
could expand you know so DHHS could
co-locate with you and save uh you know
the save of the state money and DHHS
money
yeah it's going to vary by by college
around the state and particular location
I'll tell you that the place where we've
spent the most time discussing this
happens to be nhti the largest physical
footprint of any of our colleges and has
some great potential for reallocation of
space I spoke with Patrick Tompkins the
new president of Manchester this morning
about this and they are looking at the
physical footprint they currently occupy
how they're using that space and the
intent is to figure out is there a way
to bring their primary uses of the space
together more cohesively to free up
other parts of the campus for other
purposes and again whether it's state
agencies or
non-profit agencies or other
organizations whose missions are
complementary to the work that we do
that would make more impact for those
communities we see real potential there
I I will say I I had reached out to
commissioner arlinghaus to acknowledge
that the state has right of first
refusal on anything that we have and and
for me that's probably one of the best
opportunities to partner with the state
uh to see if there's some co-locations
moments across the state
over five percent
over what period of time or well covert
has hurt a lot of people
what
if asked what would convince
my constituents that we should invest
more money
I mean because the governor's budget um
that that is a good amount but which I
was very happy to see it what would
convince my constituents to want to
invest more money
in a system that right now is not
busting at the seams and actually has
slowed down a bit well I think I shared
in our first meeting that that's a
national Trend and it's been going on
for 12 years since the end of the last
Great Recession 2011 you can see a peak
in Community College enrollments and
then the the trend has been down
but the need is not less and it's not
about the demographics of fewer 18 year
olds in high school
one of the things that we saw with a
pandemic not just how acutely disruptive
it was to the lives of students who
attend community colleges but to
everybody it required the rapid scaling
up of different kinds of occupations it
required people to change the way they
worked and what they were doing
our our vision over time for the
non-traditional the adult learner is
that the need for education is actually
going to grow and it's not going to be
the two or four years of college that
you have After High School that sets
your path for the rest of your life it's
the education that you need that's
accessible in an ongoing basis as your
life changes industry you know for let's
hope for not another pandemic but
Industries change technology changes
people's lives and interests and
abilities change and they've got to be
able to prepare for that so we are
trying to reorient the way that we serve
that part of the the universe of
Learners who are not 18 and 19 coming
out of high school having said that the
other part of our work is more
foundational helping students get that
good start so the dual enrollment to
allow academically motivated students to
to rise to that challenge and maintain
the passion for learning that will set a
course for the rest of their lives to
help those students and their families
who are facing challenges with
affordability and not just the neediest
families but the middle class family who
is not going to get federal aid to
manage the cost of post-secondary
Education whether that's a certificate
in welding whether that's a degree
whether that's a path to medicine
whatever it happens to be we're trying
to manage that as well
um I think I shared in our first meeting
the most recent data from Department of
Education 22 percent of the students in
this state are eligible for free and
reduced lunch
that number is more than one in five and
it's you know more than that here in
Concord much more than that in
Manchester Rochester Laconia Berlin
Nashua you can go around the state and
find communities where that
affordability for post-secondary
education or for life is an increasing
pressure on this state if it's a barrier
to people engaging in the workforce
because they can't get the education
that allows them to pursue those
opportunities that's going to be
detrimental to them but it's going to be
really detrimental to this state
you can automate a lot of things and you
can you can Outsource some things but so
much of what we're going to need in this
state in healthcare and Human Services
in
travel and tourism here in this state
can't be outsourced can't be replaced by
technology and we've got to find ways to
have opportunities for people to be
engaged in what's here in New Hampshire
so
from my vantage point the demographics
and the trend lines have been down but
it's only because we haven't been able
to reorient our focus on where there's a
growing need that we've got to meet
foreign
advertising you know I don't see a lot
of advertising community college system
and you look at Southern New Hampshire I
mean they're flush with money and I mean
they're all I mean you you go across the
country and you'll you'll see an ad for
them uh what what are you what are your
plans to uh get your message out
well let me say that our best
endorsement are our graduates and you
you walk in any hospital and you don't
go far before you've run into one of our
folks if you need to have a vehicle
serviced in the state pretty good chance
you're going to have one of our
graduates working on your car
and go through almost anything that
people need in New Hampshire and it's
Word of Mouth
we're we're I said earlier we want to be
respectful in the budget process of what
we asked for also fairly Frugal about
how we tell our story and maybe a little
bit you know too too subtle but
it's a resource question
right well I want to I just want to make
a comment when I get service from you
know kids or I mean everybody's a kid to
me I guess I'm so old but uh you know
I'm very proud especially in HTI I mean
you see some kids that really are really
outstanding what they do you know
Radiology for one or a nurse I mean it's
dental hygienist I mean I mean every
place you go it seems so you run into a
you know a community college student and
that's that's very refreshing I I should
add one other point which is that if
you're not seeing our ads that's
probably because you're not our primary
demographic and I I should acknowledge
that more of more of what we do is
digital and it's in places where we know
we're going to find the people who are
looking for us so is no offense and
then then maybe we've got to find your
foreign
just to build up on representative hits
questions about you know in you know
what we can do
I find that training
has to be in person to really truly be
effective we've all seen the impact that
kovit had on our students of all ages
from K to graduates college students to
everybody
there are times and places where you
know remote learning is possible and
works fine I mean God knows I took some
of my CPA credits I you know I took
accounting classes from LSU remotely and
there are times when it works but the
vast majority of this career changing
type classes only work in person and you
know there are certain places where
technology can help you be more
effective and whatnot but there is no
replacement for that person in that
classroom that is an expert on that
topic teaching students in person and
seriously I I I think that
the impact on the people who need to
change their careers and you help them
be successful in a different field
because those changes keeps up keep
happening Industries restructure all the
time being able to help people like that
is is a huge plus to the state and we
really need to make sure those
capabilities remain there thank you
thank you
lifelong learning it seems community
colleges there was a strong connection
with lifelong learning and the community
college system and with all the
challenges that you're facing and the
workforce issues that you're Chase
facing
it seems community colleges have moved a
little bit away from that which I think
you know it's to a benefit of the state
with regards to Workforce uh perhaps but
can you speak a little bit to what you
offer in the traditional lifelong
learning
path or
so that representative Petrie can take a
well
again a lot of that is in non-credit
space and it then it does tend to be
career focused but we we continue to
offer a broad spectrum of curriculum for
people who simply want to be engaged and
we make it affordable and accessible in
physical locations around the state
um I'm not sure I can offer you uh a
uh so I want to go back to the child uh
care Workforce
um developmental discussion that we had
I guess that was last week or a little
longer ago
um so I remember I recall that you had
um spoken about the you know complex
complexity and um
like multi-step
tuition program or educational program
for early childhood development and I
remember you saying one of the
challenges was that you know students
who start that pipeline may find it
difficult to finish the pipeline because
of the increased coursework and those
costs
um
if that is my correct to my memory
um could you speak about what this new
you know budget proposal will be doing
for that
um kind of
complex problem and what you hope to see
from this you know increased funding
sure we'll bring forward a more complete
proposal funding is is approved but the
basic concept is that right now there
are Grant programs that cover certain
parts of the program certain courses but
not all of the courses
and they also have a significant work
requirement that goes with it and those
two things together seem to be
impediments to students actually being
able to complete the program so the
additional funding fills in some of the
funding gaps and also would allow
students to back off of some of the
employment work so they could focus on
the School portion of it to complete the
degree so it's not not devoid of the
experiential learning or the Hands-On
component but it creates I think a
better balance and more seamless we
administratively can handle the back end
of ensuring that the student makes
progress rather than the student having
to figure out which courses are covered
how they're going to fund the other
Mr
um chair could I just
finish that thought with a would you
believe I think that's going to be
really helpful for trying to you know
chip away at our child care
um crisis here in the state of New
Hampshire by providing a little more
help for students to get through that
tuition room if that was a statement
then I agree if that was a question I'd
be happy to respond
I agree uh thank you just a quick
question um we have a growing number of
children with disabilities and a
specifically autism
um
the community colleges are a great
opportunity for many of those students
do you have support systems in place
because academically many children with
autism can achieve at high levels but
they
they need some social supports what's
available for a student with a
disability at the community college each
each campus has a coordinator
responsible for identifying
accommodations for students with
appropriate documentation as you
probably know there's difference between
post-secondary and K through 12 and the
onus is on the student to bring forth
the documentation
we are in some cases working with campus
resources in some cases Voc Rehab to put
together supports for the student but
again it's Case by case and I I agree
with your observation a lot of the
students run into barriers that keep
them from reaching our doors we'd like
thank you uh to follow up on
representative Heath
um I'm not sure if you familiar with the
Met program it's it's a mentoring
program in it and I was I went to a CSG
uh Summit uh down in Rhode Island and
they had a mentoring program where you
like this this one autistic uh student
uh was following a civil engineer now
they don't have a physical classroom
but they it's it's almost like a
directed study and they they formulate a
plan and I mean this kid was awesome I
mean he really you know he he gave the
keynote speech you know to the group and
I mean any a
National president was here a aft was
there uh and I mean it uh
it would be nice if we could come up and
actually the
uh teacher that came up with this
program
uh he was actually a teacher in
Winchester and you know and but he he
devised it and it's now in 68
they have 68 schools around the world to
do this but the mentoring side is what
I don't know if you could come up with
something like that or do you have
something like that thank you
nothing specific I can respond to sir
I just had a follow-up question on the
point brought that by representative
Heath on uh you know kids with adults
young adults with disabilities I would
assume but I want to double check that
part of the services you offer them is
to try to help them find the fields
where their limitations would not
prevent them from achieving their
potential because I can think of
specifics in the specific types of
conditions that would definitely be a
huge impediment into one career but
wouldn't be an impediment in one so are
you you know do they have access to the
you know kind of counseling and support
to find the right match because they
need more support than you know people
who are not challenged that way yeah I
we we have advisors to assist students
but I don't want to suggest that we've
got folks who's you know that that's
their exclusive focus and to a large
extent as the students find their way to
us with somebody helping having helped
them find the path to us where we can
then deliver the program
thank you
well thank you for your presentation and
we look forward to hb2
being translated so we don't know what's
going on uh to see what what additional
it might be in there as do we thank you
sir thank you all
okay we've got about two minutes
that makes other texts more expensive
okay in order to be on schedule we need
to get underway we welcome
and I'll turn the I'll turn the floor
red just
John
okay why don't we start by introducing
ourselves um cat
uh good morning good to see you folks
all again uh Tom Conan and I were here
last Thursday my name is Kathy
provencher I serve as the chief
administrative officer and vice
Chancellor Finance for our State
University system
and good morning everyone I'm Jim Dean
I'm the president of the University of
New Hampshire and interim Chancellor for
the usnh system
oh well no that's that's a much longer
story sir
I'm not in a room as president only as
uh as Chancellor
so we have some materials that we've
handed out to you so you'll have some
leave behind and a sense of what it is
that we're here to talk about
so starting on page two of Our Deck one
of the things that we wanted to let you
know about is that the system the
university system of New Hampshire has
not increased tuition for in-state
students for five years we've held
tuition flat for five years and of
course what that means with inflation is
that we've actually decreased tuition in
real terms it's something we're really
proud of because we think as a public
university system we need to be really
cognizant of the needs especially of the
students who are not affluent or middle
class students and we believe that
holding tuition flat for five years has
really made it more affordable for them
to to stay in New Hampshire and to get
their education
the way that yes go please go ahead
thank you uh will will the increase in
Pell Grants well how much will that help
you
to increase that the federal
government's talking about correct that
that will significantly help tell me how
much do you have a number or have you
thought about it uh overall
no I'll have to get back to you on that
but yet we have we have done
um analysis I just don't have it with me
representative
um but yes that would significantly help
so
okay that's fine
um so on page three uh the way that
we've been able to keep tuition flat
over that period of time is through some
pretty significant reduction in expenses
as you can see on page three uh 50
million dollars in total operating
expenses between fiscal 19 and fiscal 22
coming both from employee compensation
and from other operating expenses and
the reason we raise this is that we're
coming to the state asking for
additional funding and I think you would
be well within your rights to say well
how have you handled the money that
you've already gotten and are you acting
responsibly with respect to that and I
think it's clear that we are when I came
in as president of unh and then
collaborating with Kathy and the other
presidents across the system we took a
really hard look at our expenses and
said are there ways that we can operate
more effectively and we've actually done
quite a bit of cutting not by just
saying 5 percent here or 10 there but
looking at how we do things including
some consolidation of services for
example across the universities that we
had not really done before so we're very
proud of the reduction in costs that
we've been able to get over the past few
years I think they're really
unprecedented
and as you can see at the bottom of page
three uh
we're spending
less than the average New England
institution on students so we we do that
kind of benchmarking to make sure that
we're staying competitive on on
operational expenses operational
then as you go to page four stating I'm
sure the obvious but we thought we
should probably put that in there that
that we are of course experiencing
inflation uh and that we have been able
to reduce expensive uh expenses hold
tuition flat and to increase financial
aid over that period of time despite
inflation a 15 million dollar plus
what we're really about in the
University system is providing people
for the workforce of New Hampshire that
is really the central mission that we
have
um
I would be preaching to the converted to
tell you that there's a tremendous need
for Workforce in New Hampshire with
every level of Education up to and
including a university level degrees
just as an example there on page five is
a figure of graduates from the
University system of New Hampshire
working in New Hampshire in 2021 so
nearly 20 000 people there we're
collaborating collaborating excuse me
with over 2 000 Partners within the
state in terms of helping our students
to do internships and to be hired by the
employers of New Hampshire and this last
point on here that the 2X
uh and we'll probably say a little bit
more about this later we bring a lot of
people in from out of state to educate
and many of them will stay we probably
are more responsible for bringing more
people in from out of state into the
economy of New Hampshire than anyone
else is and if we can get them to
complete an internship in New Hampshire
they're twice as likely to stay which is
what we absolutely want them to do and
for that reason we enjoy a tremendous
amount of sport from the business
Community specifically the business and
industry Association which is very much
and I think we've got a slide in here
very much in support of increased
funding so I think sometimes in the past
we haven't really told that story that
we're bringing people from all over the
country into the economy of New
Hampshire and we're trying to find a way
to help them to stay and become part of
our economy and part of our Workforce
can I just one um I just want to back up
on that number Jim mentioned 20 000 new
um usnh graduates
that's only graduates who who were from
2012 to 2020 because we're sharing
information with the Department of
Employment Security so the number is
significantly larger than that right
it's just starting in 2012.
right
it's a very quick follow-up on the same
exact topic it's about 20 High 2100
graduates a year that comes here what's
your average class size
I'm trying to figure out the percentage
not just the total number
University system it's a
so moving on then to page six uh we
believe that we're doing a really some
really important work supporting the
economy and providing the professional
Workforce for the state and we've been
doing a lot as I said we've we've made
tremendous strides in reducing expenses
both on the Personnel side and on the
non-personnel side
but we're not sure that we can continue
to do it much longer without additional
funding it's getting harder and harder
to do that uh harder to keep tuition
down uh harder to have the resources to
work with employers and so we have
avoided coming to you asking for
additional funding but we think we've
done about everything we can to reduce
our costs over the past few years we'll
continue to work on that we still have
tasks for us doing that but we've taken
an awful lot of costs out of the
University system over the past few
years and I feel really good about that
and really really proud about that but
we really need your help now to be able
to continue to fulfill that mission of
graduating students to help the New
as I've said and now moving to page
seven
um we're really happy to have the
support of the business Community uh
Kathy and others just organized an event
a couple of weeks ago where we had
Business Leaders from around the state
come and and talk in support of the
University system and what we're doing
to try and provide employment I joined
the board of the business and industry
Association because of my background as
a business school dean those are sort of
my people so I feel really comfortable
in that and we're trying to find ways to
for the University system to be
friendlier to the businesses in New
Hampshire and I think we've made a lot
of progress with that I've also formed
my own business advisory council at UNH
so that I have the business Community
within New Hampshire has my year and the
year of the people at UNH we think it's
really Central because those are the
people that are doing the hiring and
moving the unit moving the workforce
forward so we're really grateful for the
support of the business and industry
Association
moving to page eight this is really to
put our request in context so you see
the level of appreciations going back to
fiscal year 2010 and out through fiscal
year 2025.
what I'm what we're trying to convey
with this slide is we don't think that
this is an outrageous uh kind of a
request what we're really asking is to
get back to the level of funding that we
had in 2011.
um and you can see that there was a 50
cut in our funding in 2011. uh if we
were able to to get the funding that we
requested we will be back to and
slightly above
discounting inflation so forget
inflation just in terms of current
dollars where we were in
2011. uh where we are now is about 11
and a half percent lower
in constant dollars than where we were
in 2011. uh we believe that the state
budget
and what's the term of art Kathy general
fund the general fund has increased by
about six percent at least over that
period of time so there's now basically
a 17 point gap between where we were in
2011 and where we are now so we're not
looking to be disproportionately funded
we'd just like to get back to where we
and with that I'll turn to Kathy to talk
about the next couple slides so on on
slide nine I want to talk about what it
is the University system is seeking with
this
um additional funding and
it it isn't to grow the cost structure
or anything like that it is primarily
targeted to Plymouth and Keen
to provide resources for Plymouth and
Keene to build infrastructure for those
internships that President Dean just
mentioned as well as other business
Partnerships in The Lakes Region North
Country and Monadnock region of the
state I think I might have mentioned
last Thursday that UNH invested
five or six years ago in um building a
pretty robust internship program but
frankly Plymouth and Keene do not have
the resources to do that and we'd like
to partner with the state so that we can
increase that Talent pipeline from from
keen and Plymouth into into those
regions of the state that that need it
and obviously Plymouth and Keen are
economic anchors in in their regions
uh the other part of the additional
funding is also targeted to Plymouth and
Keene to help Plymouth and Keene
maintain the level of financial aid for
New Hampshire students that it has now
um we have the granite guarantee where
Pell eligible students
attend our institutions with no tuition
and Plymouth and Keane need that so
support so we can continue to
compete on price and keep our New
Hampshire students here
and then that last piece is relative to
Cooperative Extension in fiscal 25 that
will bring I believe will bring
Cooperative Extension back to its 2011
levels Cooperative Extension has
remarkable reach across every region of
the Granite State and to be able to
um
use the research that's done at UNH to
get that information out to Granite
Staters is is critically important so
that's the piece that's that's added
um in fiscal 25. we had requested
eight million dollars now I'm on the
Plymouth and Keen strength and Workforce
Partnerships we had requested eight
million dollars in fiscal 25 and the
governor is recommending three million
dollars so of our total request across
the entire biennium including the three
percent efficiency and the additional
prioritized needs we had requested
199.4 million and the governor is
proposing
194.4 million so he pulled back on that
strength and Workforce Partnerships at
and just because I know there's a lot of
jargon in a lot of areas is everybody
when we say Pell eligible is that
language everyone's familiar with
right so okay
it's a synonym for the the poor students
basically okay
so moving then to to slide 10 uh one of
the challenges we have is that so many
New Hampshire students uh who go on to
college leave the state in order to do
it and one of the reasons they do that
is because of the relative price of
universities outside the state versus
inside the state and we've tried to
address that as as I've already said a
couple of times by trying to keep
tuition flat and and here's where the
the narrative that people believe about
tuition is is really not is any longer
accurate so you've probably heard
double-digit increases Beyond inflation
and so on so that may be true in some
places but uh at the University system
the increase has been zero for five
years and if you take into consideration
inflation I can't do that math in my
head but it's probably a 10 drop five
percent drop some number like that so
that's something to really be proud of I
know that New Hampshire as a state
Prides itself on being cost conscious
and Frugal and efficient and I think
it's fair to say that your State
University system is actually really an
important part of that
um
if we are able to get additional funding
from the state then we will be able to
continue the tuition freeze making it
more competitive for students to be able
to come here to stay here in New
Hampshire and
as
I'll go off script here for a second and
just say that as president of the
University of New Hampshire one of the
practices which I've enjoyed the most is
I have office hours for students
and so I've spent lots and lots of time
in my office with students
it's 20 minutes per student and I've
learned an awful lot from them and
you know I would say if there's one
thing that binds them together is that
we don't really have students with
relatively few exceptions who come from
affluent backgrounds they're working
class kids middle class kids in some
cases really poor kids but but they come
to the university to work and to develop
themselves and to make something of
themselves and there's
tens of thousands of them out in the
economy now who have started from Modest
circumstances and we've given them the
opportunity no institution can make
someone successful all we can do is give
them the opportunity and I'm just as
pleased as I can be to see them uh to
see them become successful and one of
the Privileges of being a president is
that you almost can it's almost like you
have the ability to fast forward because
I'll have a student in my office in the
morning who comes from a town somewhere
in in New Hampshire and then in the
afternoon I may go to see an Alum who's
20 years older than that and I see that
they become successful and I know that's
the story and that's what we're helping
to do again they're doing it themselves
but we're giving them the opportunity to
do it and that's the kind of support
that we're hoping that you can help us
to continue
a very quick question since we are
talking about you know the number of
students that uh you know graduate how
many of your students in an average
class are New Hampshire residents and
how many come from out of state to study
here just ballpark I'm not looking you
know about 4 000 graduates how many of
them were New Hampshire residents how
many of them were out of state students
who just came to study here across the
university system it's about a 50 50
so in on slide 11 I think we've talked
about this a little bit already that we
are really important in terms of
bringing in students from out of state
and trying to get them to stay in New
Hampshire to be part of our uh part of
our employment that the internships make
a big difference these students come in
from out of state if they get the
internship they're twice as likely to
stay and so this funding would help us
to have more internships for students
which means more workers for the
workforce of of New Hampshire and also
just in passing I want to mention that
of course each of the universities are
important economically for the regions
that we serve but I think it's
particularly important to think about
Plymouth State University and Keene
State College if I try to think about
what those regions would be like if
those institutions were to fail it's
it's really a nightmare to think about
that and so this is one of the other
reasons that we really have put Keenan
Plymouth in first place in terms of
getting funding from this initiative
because those regions are so dependent
on those institutions and those unit
those institutions are a bit fragile at
we talk a little bit on page 12 about
Cooperative Extension as you know the
University of New Hampshire is a
land-grant institution which means that
Cooperative Extension is Central to our
mission
our mission in 1866 when we were formed
was to educate the children of farmers
to become effective in farming and also
the mechanical Arts
uh by coincidence it it's uh 2023 we are
100 years from when the name was changed
uh
to the University of New Hampshire
uh we're very proud of that we're going
to do some celebrations of that this
year but we've really never lost track
of that that original uh original
Mission uh many of our students come
from rural areas we have a very active
partnership with 4-H they visit us each
year and do a lot of work with our our
faculty we continue to have
programs both for horses and cows Dairy
Barnes and the horse barn and so that
that really continues but extension goes
well beyond that so extension is working
around the state as it says on the slide
We Touch over 20 000 people a year in
New Hampshire and recently just within
the last couple of months a tour that
our colleague Tom Cronin helped to
organize we visited places all over New
Hampshire including two uh I say
municipalities because one's a town and
one's a city Rochester and Franklin and
our extension teams are working with
them to do economic Redevelopment in
those areas and help those towns to
recreate their economies after they've
lost some of the industries that had
kept them going for so long so extension
while you might think about what's on my
soil like and what kind of seeds do I
need and we still do all of that but it
really goes well beyond that as well and
something we're very proud of extension
helps us to address some of the most
important challenges that the state is
facing aging substance abuse and so on
Mental Health kinds of things we have a
really capable leader in that area Ken
Lavalley who is just a a bundle of
energy and it would be really great to
give them some additional help they also
are at funding levels that are beneath
so in summary as we get to we have not
quite in summary yet but I do think that
that this page 13 is a bit of a summary
uh that additional funding will help us
to support the workforce needs and the
quality of life in New Hampshire help us
to increase Aid to retain New Hampshire
high school graduates support for
business collaboration to train and
retain usnh graduates and also support
to address the health and well-being
challenges of our residents this is
really what we're looking for support to
and that that's the request that's in
house bill one
um we did
um
I was listening to the governor's
address to house finance yesterday and
there we haven't seen House Bill 2 yet
but there are a couple yeah there are
there the governor did mention a couple
of projects for for the University that
are in-house Bill too so we wanted to
mention those as well and now that Jim
has had an opportunity to take a breath
on page 14.
um
an eight million dollar investment in
the Whittemore Center
the winamore center
um has quite a bit of deferred
maintenance
it it would if you're ever interested
love to have you over for a tour
um the the eight million dollar State
investment I think um we're thinking
about is a public-private university
partnership
that the university would put dollars in
donors would put dollars in and the
state would put dollars in to have
um
a center that the state can be proud of
a facility that D1 hockey players would
be proud of
um it's used by more than the UNH hockey
team and and really to to build pride in
the state and and the university so
thank you as being facetious yesterday
when I asked about why not football but
um the Whittemore Center has been our
Splendid resource for our high schools
and for all our teams for many many
reasons I I've gone to the Whittemore
Center for all kinds of Not Just Hockey
but many many things
so I know that it's possible to use that
as a revenue generating facility
is it and how does that work and are you
trying to promote that more
that's an excellent question thank you
so much yes and it has been used for a
number of things
we actually are asking that question on
campus now and we're utilizing our
business School faculty and students to
do an analysis to see what Revenue
opportunities there are some of the
people some of our alums who are
contributing funding to this are also
saying let's see what else we can do to
generate more Revenue so you're in good
company with that idea one other and
this is I'm sorry
well maybe I'll just finish that detail
and then go to so one one last thing I
wanted to say about the whittlemore
center is that you you may or may not
know this I'm never clear how well these
stories get out but one of the elements
of the University that we're incredibly
proud of is called Northeast passage and
Northeast passage is an organization
that's part of unh that facilitates
participation in athletic competition by
people who have one sort of disability
or handicap or another and hockey is
actually one of the activities that not
only that they enjoy but that we've we
have helped to train a number of sled
hockey athletes who have competed at the
international level and the Olympics and
so on but that's the small number the
biggest number just out there enjoying
being able to exercise part of this
renovation would allow the Northeast
passage hockey players should be able to
use the locker room at Whitmore Center
so that they could use the ice at the
Whitmore Center uh and they're they're
really quite inspiring so I just wanted
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
um normally a building project we see in
HB 2025 and almost half of hb25 is
involved with college buildings uh it's
unusual to have this in hp2
and normally you raise a lot of this
money yourself so that um you know and I
remember almost 20 years ago when I was
on the higher education study committee
and we went around to several campuses
and and finally the board of unh
admitted they weren't spending enough on
maintenance
and we were reluctant to keep giving
them new buildings if they weren't
taking care of the ones we already gave
them so they decided at at that time
like I don't know it was 95 or something
that yeah they did need to spend more in
maintenance instead of letting a
building deteriorate and then say you
need to replace it so I don't know if
that's still ongoing but normally
construction projects end up in eight HP
40 25 so
so um thank you for the question
representative Weiler
um just a point of clarification it's my
understanding that half of the state's
capital budget is not going to college
universities I I don't know how much the
general fund portion of the bonded
portion is this year on HP 25 but if
it's around 125 million I think the
university system is allocated 17
million
um so and I can only speak uh I have
been at the University system for almost
nine years I've missed you thank you
representative and um
on your question about deferred
maintenance
we've had a requirement probably for the
past seven plus years
um our annual capital budget at the
University system
of the University system funds is about
65 million dollars
and where that comes from is that's the
amount of depreciation
that we have each year on our buildings
so it makes sense that you reinvest that
in your Capital plant for for our our
programming so when we think about and
this we'd certainly have this
conversation with how house Public Works
I think we do in a couple of weeks when
you think about all the funding for the
University system Capital program if
we're if the university system is
contributing 25 and the state is
contributing eight and a half because
the 17 is over a two-year period
um there's some of it is bonded debt
only for
res halls and dining facilities we
cannot bond for our academic buildings
so the the um anyway I just want to give
you a background on our entire Capital
program and we've now started we have a
assessment report done so that we can
make sure that facilities
um
are being kept up where they should be I
can tell you not all of them are because
you have to prioritize
um so on the question of hb2 versus hb25
representative I I don't have an answer
for that I believe from my time as state
treasurer
most of what's in hb25 that's General
funded is bonded
and I believe the governor's intention
in including this in hb2 is that it not
be bonded it be funded with
Surplus that the state has generated I
mean that's not to say you couldn't
rethink hb25 but that's what I'm that's
what I'm thinking of the hb2 versus hb20
sorry I was a little off I'm going back
a few years on 1825 but I haven't looked
at it in deep for a while but I remember
at one point it did seem like almost
half the buildings for for many many
years there was a program we're getting
in the weeds here a little bit but there
was a program called uh keep it was an
acronym for knowledge but and the state
was funding
I believe 30 million dollars each
biennium
for University system academic buildings
that was peeled back significantly
maybe when it ended in 13 or 14 it could
be then when we came out of the gate
there was 3 million over a two-year
period
so in the upcoming biennium it it was it
is 17 million over the biennium and and
so happy to talk more about the capital
but but that's that's where we are now
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the questions you already know
that Finance is the most weed friendly
committee so don't be afraid of the
weeds a quick question on the um with a
more Center project we are obviously
asking for eight Millions from the state
budget could you just give me a rough
breakdown of where the other 22 million
will be coming from
source of funds yeah about 13 million
dollars of it will be coming from the
University and the rest would be coming
from private donors
thank you
thank you can we go back to uh Keene
State and Plymouth and the difference
between the three million that is in the
second year of the biennium and I've
lost my page and your request for the 8
million uh can you say what you do with
that that other five million dollars in
the so
the um we will do everything we can with
the governor's recommended budget
um
at funding at the level that the
university system
requested
um I think we could build out more
robust programs
for internships and Partnerships at with
our business communities in those areas
we will do everything we can
um but but that that
the the five million dollar reduction is
significant
but but I don't
I want to be clear that that
um
the university system is pleased with
the increase that the governor has
proposed I've been around here quite a
number of years and and we have not
received
um
meaningful I shouldn't or sizable
increases
um we could do more if we had more
yeah thank you Mr chairman uh
on uh the university system itself what
what do we gain by being a university
system versus say Plymouth and Keenan
it's a really good question I I think
that probably the the biggest
uh the biggest Advantage is the
opportunity to have services that are
provided to all of the universities as
opposed to having to reproduce those
services for each individual
universities so I'm not going to
remember all of them but probably the
biggest ticket item right now is
information technology so we have one
Information Technology organization that
serves Keen Plymouth and UNH and that
that wasn't always like that in fact
three-ish years ago we made that change
which resulted in several million
dollars in savings we have to my
knowledge always had a Consolidated
general counsel's office well for a long
long time right and we save a lot of
money there versus having individual
councils for each one
we are increasingly centralizing human
resources which also results in savings
so that we can have consistency of
policies but also have the economies of
scale associated with HR working across
the University Systems there's probably
less tangible advantages about
coordination of marketing and things
like that but the main thing would be a
provision of of services in a
centralized way that saves us a lot of
money
just to give you very specific
so
um
Plymouth and keen and UNH each issuing
their own debt would make very little
sense even payroll my office is
responsible for payroll making sure
there's enough money in the bank
coordinating all the treasury functions
if Plymouth and Keenan and UNH each had
to do all that TR I I think it would be
highly inefficient we're driving toward
fission we have to drive toward more
efficiency and and so I think that
that would not benefit certainly our
cheer I just want to make a comment um
first of all I want to just send
accolades to you for working with um
Mike skeleton in the Chamber of Commerce
I really see the university system is
kind of the engine for New Hampshire
we're an aging State our young
population has declined significantly
we're in desperate need of of
um employees I live in Manchester
um we're a hub for technology and
without the benefit of our University
system I don't know what we do you are
producing our future and you're keeping
so many students that come from out of
state
in our state because they're going to
jobs that are so and what Dean came is
doing is so remarkable and and I see
what they're doing at UNH Manchester and
the the labs that they have in place so
I just want to say yay because I am so
pleased with I've seen and learned your
Innovation Center that you have on
campus is something that I would
encourage all of us to take a look at
because it's just extraordinary but I
want to say thank you because I I just
feel like UNH is playing a significant
role in the future of our state right
now more than ever before
thank you Mr chair
thank you thank you again I'd like to
give you the opportunity to speak to how
UNH is perceived outside of New
Hampshire one thing in particular when
you're hiring faculty how many uh when
you make an offer to someone How likely
is that person going to come to teach at
UNH as opposed to deciding to go to
another University but you know more
generally how is UNH perceived outside
because you have some very unique and
Powerful programs at the University
foreign
we have had a great deal of success in
recruiting faculty to the university I I
don't know that I've ever heard of a
situation in which we've wanted to hire
into a certain discipline and we've been
unable to do that
um are we able to hire every single and
no of course not the people we make
offers to
um
disciplines are different some of them
are much more competitive than others if
you take uh
sadly from my point of view the
humanities disciplines there are fewer
jobs available uh nationally for
professors in the humanities and so it's
not at all unusual to get
150 applicants for a job in history or
English or philosophy or what have you
uh
and so of course we do very well uh in
hiring in those areas then there's other
areas where we have and you've
acknowledged this in your question where
we have a national and even in
international reputation so for example
in anything having to do with space
anything having to do with the ocean we
are among the world leaders in research
and and teaching in those spaces and
people really come in and look to to
come to to UNH
um to be able to work in those areas
uh I was mentioning in a previous
conversation today that we had the
the NASA administrator the head of NASA
is called the administrator I think
that's funny but that's his title and so
so he came to visit with us a couple of
years ago
in in conjunction with a very big grant
that we've gotten and had a morning of
presentations most of which featured our
students so the idea that you come to
UNH you're a student and not just a
graduate student but an undergraduate
student you can present to the head of
NASA about
space plasma and other things that I
don't understand I think it's pretty
great so that really does attract we
just got a big Grant on Space plasma so
I can't wait to have them explain to me
what exactly it is I'm all for it
because it was 250 million dollars so it
must be good
so so there's that
um you know because you have some
background in this that universities are
really a collection of different
disciplines and it would be a different
answer for for each discipline
um I'll by coincidence pick music and
music education we have a great
reputation in there many of the music
teachers across the state of New
Hampshire come from from the system
because keen and Plymouth both also have
really strong music education programs
we do as well and I think that's
something to be proud of when I when I
think of
of the kids learning about music and
what that means learning to play an
instrument or learning about different
kinds of music I'm just really proud
that we play a role in that I mean you
don't make really much money being a
music teacher but you're doing really
important work
I would say you know to take the broader
we do not have we have never had a very
big marketing budget at the University
um in fact
the the marketing budget for uh
University of Southern New Hampshire
dwarfs hours which is why they have TV
ads in a bus that runs around the
in fact their their budget I believe in
the hundreds of millions of dollars just
for marketing so we're not going to do
that we're a public university having
said that we've recently recognized that
we in a competitive industry and Kathy's
talked about this that we need to do a
better job of getting our message out so
we have done a couple of things we have
communications and marketing person at
the system and we've recently hired a
senior person marketing at the
University of of New Hampshire
and interestingly while you would think
marketing is about driving Revenue which
of course it is
our new director of marketing has also
said that we're not spending money as
intelligently as we could and so we're
consolidating media buys and the kinds
of things that Professionals in that
area do which will both Drive revenue
and reduce cost and get our reputation
out there a bit more sorry long answer
I just want to share a thought that I
mentioned to Kathy last week is that my
sister lives in Colorado
and she thinks that the Southern New
Hampshire University ads are for unh
just well as long as she sends someone
to UNH I think that's perfectly fine
I mean it is SN uh versus usnh there's I
still get the USPS confused with UPS so
but um I was at this is you reminded me
of something I was completely thrown off
my feet when I was hurt told that the
development department at Ohio State
University employs 600 people
okay
um
it's it's less than six but thanks for
that
it's uh so we have at there are very few
people in developmented either Keen or
Plymouth fewer than 10 in both places
UNH has a much bigger uh department and
the overall department is called
advancement that's the term of art
they're using these days and fundraising
or development is a part of that but
also alumni relations is a part of that
and event management is a part of that
as well I would say we have a few dozen
and sort of that but I will say
uh that that is an area where we have
been growing so uh the head of
advancement reports to me and she has
told me that once a development officer
is up to speed that he or she will
generate as much as two million dollars
in Revenue
um they're paid
nowhere near that there's more than a 20
to 1 return on investment for that and
our numbers uh of fundraising have gone
up every year for the last probably 10
years
thank you
um
the reason Southern New Hampshire is so
successful is because they're online
courses do you plan to go uh that
pathway at all yes we we already offer
quite a number of online courses and
both the number of courses and the
enrollment have really increased pretty
dramatically over the past few years
it's interesting and if I'm too far in
the weeds pull me back but the the
market for online courses is mostly at
the Master's Degree level that's really
the big area of growth there are not
that many undergraduate students who are
interested in having a fully online
experience many of the people who go to
Southern New Hampshire are so-called
degree completers they're people who
have some college and they want to
finish that's a really great market and
they've done you know I think they're
very they're playing an important Niche
I will say just for your purposes since
you are helping to fund the university
system that the tuition at the
University of Southern New Hampshire is
much higher than our tuition and their
success rate of successful graduation is
much much lower
so you're paying more for something that
is much less likely to get you a degree
thank you Mr chair I'm probably going to
make Kathy cringe but
I'm going to say this piece that College
tuition loans
are the source of our latest demographic
trend where are the young people
well the people that made the tuition
loan so they could move safely into the
middle class find they have such a
burden they can't afford to get married
sometimes they can't afford a house and
they certainly can't afford to have
children in many cases so where are all
the 18 year olds that generation didn't
have them and I remember 30 years ago my
daughter was in college I was paying and
she's telling me about classmates going
to borrow six hundred dollars on the
line of credit to go on spring break
I mean you need to have a class in
financial responsibility and planning
before you can go and get a hundred
thousand dollars worth of student loans
if you want
I've got some detail on this as well
thank you we've had this the station for
your question representative I would say
financial literacy should start well
before someone is in college yes when I
was State Treasurer I advocated for that
at the high school level and it didn't
go very far so I would also Point your
attention to page 19 we provided some
um outcome data on the University system
and the university system has the lowest
student loan default rate
um
actually pretty much across the country
and what that tells and
our graduation rate compared to other
publics in New England is the highest
that tells us
that we have
programs where people are graduating on
time they're able to pay down their
debts
they've made an investment they're
paying it off
again part of our problem is the ability
to compete on price
and now you're going to cringe
representative when I say this
and that for New Hampshire residents is
directly related to the amount of State
support that the university system
receives congratulations
it was just how she was going to get
there it wasn't whether she was going to
get there
um just just some a little broader
answer on debt as long as we're talking
about that so Kathy made the point that
I wanted to make which is that our our
debt repayment rate is is actually
really good but just for general
information because people talk about
college debt a lot uh get in your mind
what you think is the average amount of
debt that college graduates have
currently just think of a number in your
mind
yeah what'd you say 40.
yeah so it's so the app the average is
thirty thousand uh nationally the
average is thirty thousand and that
includes this is a really important part
that includes both graduate school debt
as well as undergraduate debt the
majority of debt is actually held by
people who go to graduate school
including business school like some of
you in this room medical school and law
school and if you take that out the
average is actually quite a bit lower
also a lot of the debt is held by
individuals who go to not-for-profit
institutions as opposed to excuse me
for-profit institutions as opposed to
non-profit so it is a problem but it's a
different problem than people think
um my daughter got an MBA
I suppose predictably enough and she
spent a bunch of money to do it but she
got a job that allows her to pay it back
that's okay if you saw the series of
Wall Street Journal articles about this
uh over the last year you'd see that one
of the big challenges is people getting
master's degrees and paying two hundred
thousand dollars for the degree and then
earning forty thousand dollars a year
there's no planet on which that makes
any sense and and I will say that the
most elite schools in the country are
some of the worst offenders
yeah you can look up Melissa corn Korn
wrote a series of articles about this
for the Wall Street Journal really
insightful thank you
thank you Mr chair
um on the chart that they referred on
page 19 there is that you know fine
print on the bottom which is perfectly
accurate that the current low default
rates are because of a lot of
moratoriums and whatnot would you be
able you know after this to maybe send
us a chart from before kovid because
that would be a bit more representative
in terms of the you know data absolutely
and we've been on the bottom of this
chart since I arrived so I will
definitely get that information I'm sure
you are but I want to see how much
further behind everybody else we get and
the other question was a bit earlier
when we were talking about online
programs and I was mentioning in the
early discussion with ccsnh that I had
to get some accounting credits after I
graduated to meet the requirements for
my CPA and I took remote learning
classes with like LSU where it was
literally you got the books and then you
had to study and you could ask minimal
questions and then you had to have a
proctored exam to you know great get
your grade
I'm completely unaware of whether a UNH
does anything like that or not and I
would just appreciate a bit of
background it's not going to be a
critical thing but just curiosity and
trying to see the full picture
so yes we do an awful lot in that area
and it's been growing quite a bit and
and the kind of thing you're talking
about is right down the middle of what
education is in 2023 we'll get you some
statistics on that thank you it's large
and growing I just want to have you to
have an opportunity so when you leave
here we'll know what your expectation
would be if we could satisfy all your
all your expectations
because right now I I see a five million
dollar Delta in the budgeted items and
then you've got these other items that
are I'm assuming are hopefully in hb2
have we covered everything so that if
yes representative but but if you could
satisfy if this committee can satisfy
all of our expectations and needs it
would be
199.4 million dollars in an operating
Grant over the biennium in house bill
one plus eight million dollars for the
Whittemore Center and a million and a
half dollars for the interoperability
it's called the cryptocurrency quality
assurance Center
um that's in-house Bill too now again if
there's conversation about changing the
way House Bill 25 works that's fine too
I get the point the governor made a
point in hb2 that's he's considering a
surplus fund so he wants a straight pay
rather than going to one that gets
bonded so now I I remember the way he
emphasized it thank you okay if you
folks had some follow-up questions I
just wanted to make you aware when I
when Tom and I were here last Thursday
in one of the appendices we've added
um some answers to those questions
um I just got some demographic
information this morning I can follow up
with that but some of the answers to
your questions you can find in the
appendix to this this morning's
information I have a question yes I I
thank you Mr chairman
um endowments and how much effect does
okay so if you go to page 26 here we go
you asked this question last week
representative thank you
um the
well it's that on the right side of that
page
six mil 6.2 million dollars is going to
scholarship
for the um
the University Systems part of the
endowment
um
there's another piece of this though
that there are two endowments the
University of New Hampshire has its own
foundation and then the university
system so it it's probably more around
10 million dollars it goes to
scholarships from
restricted endowments every year and
endowments sorry in terms of
philanthropic gifts to the university
the number one by far Target for
philanthropic gifts is scholarships that
when we go out to donors that's what we
ask for make it easier for the kids to
be able to afford college and and it's a
I don't want to say it's an easy sell
but it's a relatively easy sell people
want to make it easier for kids to be
able to go
the other um and you're probably all
well aware of this the other thing about
endowments is that these scholarships
are derived from earnings on the the
dollars that a donor gives so it's
called payout to purpose we call it
payout purpose and so
about four and a half percent
gets paid out to purpose
on an annual basis based on the
12-month rolling fair market value of
thank you Mr chair and again thank you
for taking the many questions if you
look on your slide 24 you know the
reward for answering a question from
last week is that you get more questions
asked
um you are pointing out the number of
graduates that they enrolled out of
state and we were talking earlier about
the graduation rates of the ones that
stay in state do we have any data on the
graduation rates of the New Hampshire
high school graduates that go to out of
state schools I understand that may be
very tough to put together but do we
have anything so I don't have graduation
rates but I just got this this morning
specific to your question last week
about well has humane's strategy been
effective
61 now the numbers aren't giant but 61
percent
increase in the number of our New
Hampshire
High School grads
went to UMaine in 2020 compared to 2010.
again the numbers aren't really big
it's about you know 40 more students but
I'll tell you 40 New Hampshire students
in the system of our size matters so I
would conclude based on this information
that UMaine strategy has been effective
thank you for the follow-up appreciate
it
I know with um donor advice funds
sometimes you get into a pickle because
they're too restricted to you know
blue-eyed Lithuanian who wants to study
you know something
um well some of your scholarships go
back
um quite a ways have you run into
problems with scholarships that have
been too restrictive or even a
scholarship that for a field that
basically no longer exists after 100
years
I wish we'd been raising money a hundred
years ago
our our efforts in development are
actually quite a bit newer it's an area
of catch-up for us that's one of the
reasons why you heard me say earlier I'm
investing in development officers is to
try and play catch-up yeah we have that
um if you have a situation like that you
sound like you've been around this just
because of the language you're using uh
we'll go back to the representative of
the donors sometimes it's children or
grandchildren and try to see if we can
renegotiate it there are also
conventions about if there's no one that
you can really contact what you could
reasonably do to interpret the donor's
intent and we do try to do that because
the worst thing is to have this money
sitting there and you can't spend it
that's awful
well a number of years ago we even went
to Probate Court yeah
that we for just that reason and there
was no donor representative that we
could reach out to the other thing that
I would say was and I'm sure you know
this as well we try to not have people
give these really restrictive
left-handed Brown I mean what people
want to do it but you try to keep them
doing it because it just you can't spend
the money it's awful
okay
thank you very much thank you I thank
you all for the time today we really
foreign
yes
it's amazing
uh
Mr chairman um good afternoon Charlie
McIntyre New Hampshire lottery uh with
me as our Chief Financial Officer Jim
durris and it's a simple one-page
handout
um I'm a big fan of a fan of simple and
visual and that would be the handout you
have which is both
um obviously it's a graph as well as a
box of numbers
what it does is it reflects the revenue
transfers to the state from New
Hampshire lottery as well as what that
transfer costs to state in terms of
operating expenses
if you can triple net revenue and not
increase expenses in the private sector
that's called better than a good
and so
um
I would submit to you that we've been
remarkably efficient with people's money
and it has been reflected both on our
expenses as well as a return to
education I would note that this year
our transfer number was increased our
current profit estimate for the year is
now 170.8 million dollars which is an
increase of
30 million dollars to the general to the
education trust fund which is money you
folks get to spend uh that we take no
position on how you spend it
um that's a problem
too much money
if you folks would stop sending us have
to do I could yeah no I I appreciate it
but certainly we try to do our best if
you could imagine
um on a number of occasions we've been
recognized as one of the top lotteries
in North America in terms of growth so
we're proud of that despite the problem
having too much money I would submit to
you California wishes that same problem
right
question do you have a question Tom
thank you
um is this the page you're talking about
that shows yeah
this is a hundred and no this does not
quite readers those are the actual the
the last so the current our current
estimate is an estimate it's fiscal year
23 which is not reflected in this
Graphics okay yeah so 170 and 30.8 yes
operating expenses are going to be 15
million is that what this is
in the governor's budget
15 and 14 yeah 15 yes so FY 24. guess
what I was looking at yes thank you so
that would be there that would be the uh
Governor's submitted budget um
15.2294
is fy24
and for that we get 170 million well
that's this year actually this year for
13 million dollars you get 170 million
back and also realized one of the best
parts about our money is it's just a
permission to expend
the budget you folks approve
we spend from our Revenue stream we
don't actually receive any funding from
you folks okay it's just a deduction and
that's pursuant to article 6B of the
State Constitution which says revenues
minus expenses equals are trying to
thank you for explaining that thank you
basically an Enterprise fund correct
yeah we do Enterprise accounting our CFO
does an annual report which is submitted
to fiscal actually which just lasts a
month yeah December yeah
um
General yeah and so
um there'll be a to this point as to our
budget there'll be a further request
um that is not before you today but I
certainly I want to speak to it it's
there was a request
um during the governor's budget phase
for a 1.189 expenditure for a customer
relation management piece of software
called Salesforce which will be
contained within oit's budget which
would come out of our budget essentially
and so I wanted to sort of brief you
that on that as well as I'll follow up
with a submission as to what that
entails uh it's really
currently we're doing customer relations
on Post-it notes and emails and the like
and really migrating to custom relation
management software will improve our
business but also improve our
constituent Services which as you can
imagine we we get a lot of phone calls
for an agency we get a lot of phone
calls particularly as we've expanded
what it is we do as well as where we do
it I mean sports betting alone has been
an entirely New Vertical of
30 000 customers a month and so it's
been a challenge
so that would be certainly
um
a request made of you folks but it'll be
contained within oit's budget which is
1.189 million
we do a lot of there's a lot of work
done on Salesforce yeah yeah
okay okay yeah it's division one oit is
on division one and then we there's
there's just a pass-through obviously
they bill us for what they do so
yeah that's a one-time expense it's not
a recurring expense it's just the to buy
the software and pay for the
implementation of the software
question yeah thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you for being here
um when do you expect that to be online
Salesforce it would be certainly after
you folks approve it and I think six
months thereafter
is what the
realistically probably 20 25 by the time
it's implemented
yeah so it would be approved I mean
fiscally you're 25. yes yeah yeah that's
cool right so you know and I have one
complaint at Mega Millions jackpot was
just over the Border should have been in
New Hampshire
uh yes that person wishes it was too
they cost them 50 million dollars to
income tax
yes Maine had just increased their state
income tax by two percent so it went
from 40 million to 50 million dollars
they paid in state income taxes in Maine
if they just driven to Rochester bought
it and then declared residency in New
Hampshire
it would have been quite the savings
store it was it was bought in Lebanon
Maine yeah I know yeah and so it's
literally a mile to the Border in
Rochester they would have been
um ever so much richer not that they're
not rich now but
yeah main the revenue commissioner had a
windfall
and so certainly uh happy to answer your
questions I know you folks have a busy
schedule our budget seems to be and is
generally pretty simple uh we don't have
lots of fed we don't have any federal
grants any matching any money we have to
expend we just
hope you folks approve our budget and we
it's forms the basis of what the revenue
is we expect to return to the state
um and we try to be pretty efficient
with it okay
you have a couple questions if you can
just explain some things to me on page
1210 you've got the 2 million in debt
service and that goes away
um what was that from where does that go
so as part of our long-term strategy we
bought our building
um several years ago and as part of a
the state had extra funds actually we
had extra funds we were going to
transfer more and so as a result we
prepaid for our building which we had
Debt Service on and now we own the
building outright and don't pay debt
service or you know principled interest
on it and so that's what that is that
2.7 million dollars is us our financials
would recognize a uh an asset of that
value on it okay thank you
um on can I keep going sure
on 12 11. um you've had some new things
come online with lottery so are these
positions
um you've got what seven new positions
here are these for this new it is yes
it's just it's the the vast majority of
them are to manage the growth of
Lottery operations within the state
as you can imagine it's certainly the
graph here shows we scaled up you need
to support scaling up
and can you address
um can you say a few words for the
council for responsible gambling
um that's bottom of 2011 it looks like
there's some travel it looks like you're
sending people out for training for that
can you just speak to responsible
gambling that actually brings up a point
that I was going to speak to you sticky
notes uh bring up to you that actually
is a misclassification of the class code
that should be class code 102 which is
program Contract Services
um the council responsible gambling
where just is Administrative arm of us
so they they do make their own decisions
and everything like that but they
contract out the entire amount at least
so far they contracted out to the
Council of a responsible gambling
yes I always get them mixed up or excuse
me counsel for problems yeah
um so that's that needs to be reclassed
if we can make that change that would be
great that was on our plan to talk to
you about
uh so it's not for travel no no they do
some travel but it's all contracted and
they invoice on a monthly basis so we
need to make a change class one zero two
it should be
yeah and to be very clear we have no
input on what happens with the council
for problem gambling or the responsible
gambling they're just initially tied to
use our finance department they use
functions in our building just to make
thank you okay Joe
thank you
um
how does that contract work for your
online gambling you know your your
machine whatever I don't know what you
call machines or
yeah and and because they're not very
responsive
so you mean the machines that are in the
stores no no not the machines in the
store is the one that you go online and
okay you know the the gaming machines
so the machines that are online so if
you open your phone out and want to play
Powerball through your phone that's
through a subcontractor with a called
games
um so that's through the same vendor
does that they have a call center that's
based in East Lansing Michigan
um and they're supposed to be remarkably
responsive we actually have service
level agreements with them that they're
required to return phone calls within so
many minutes they're required return
emails within so many minutes and the
like uh and certainly we keep track of
that on a daily weekly basis and so
there's a problem with that
um I'd want to know but also our sales
is this Salesforce program gonna help no
I was at a different part of the house
so as you can imagine there's two two
areas you would call
you would call them the phone number on
the the app is to them frequently our
office gets phone calls and knows how to
contact them as well as teach folks how
to call them directly as well as if
there's a problem of significance it
escalates up and then somebody higher up
call somebody higher up and makes it an
issue that contract is up for bid we're
releasing an RFP in a matter of weeks
um and you know it'll get better with
time but certainly that's how it's
handled now and if there's a problem
representative I want to know about it
like if it's a real problem please call
me yeah because the rest of the you know
that's a contract and I realize that
sometimes I don't always go as planned
so yeah no of course and certainly I
mean they're trained in a number of
functions
um and there should be no problems
particularly after we've been doing this
now for one half years I mean not
everyone's going to win that problem
but certainly there should be no
problems in terms of a customer service
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions I'm looking at some
of your lines and I'm looking at the
numbers between 22 the FY 2023 adjusted
and then a budgeted for 24.25 there are
some spikes in 23 and I'm curious
whether that's because the year is not
over and we're looking at an estimate or
there is a underlying reason starting
with uh for example uh 64 line 64 the
retirement pension benefits health
insurance
you have you're going from 299 in 22 to
470 and then down to 314 352. do you
have any you know back color on why the
470 excuse me the uh those all numbers
all come from Das and Department of
personnel I believe they they uh change
carriers at some point over the last
couple years which I know has affected
that expense along with our
um post employment benefits and things
along those lines when we make
adjustments at the end of the year
um so that would be the explanation for
something like that thank you and there
is a similar question for number item
number 20 current expenses where again
you know it goes from 335 in 22 to 529
and then it's budgeted to 445 479. again
when I'm looking for color it's you know
I'm just curious what caused it I'm
assuming it's a one-time type situation
because it doesn't show up in the budget
but just so 20 uh line 20 is current
expenses is a number of functions uh
like for example the LBA that does our
audit we pay for the audit out of that
line item
um the majority of those funds are used
to support retailers in
retail networks so for example if we're
buying bet stations which are those
blocks or terminals that you would use
to write a ticket on that comes from
there as well as
if we buy plastic dispensers if a store
has dispensers which have tickets in
them we pay for those and we replace
them with those yeah and so usually it's
meant to sort of replace what are
essentially durable goods in retail and
support them and so that Ebbs inflows as
the need Ebbs and flows fully understood
and my last quick question on uh 69
promotion and marketing you seem to plan
to hike your marketing budget by quite a
bit yes just curious you know again in
terms of
why and what do you expect the outcome
of that to be well certainly it's meant
to support the growth in Revenue
obviously uh yeah yeah I mean you know
it's sort of fundamentally as you can
imagine we run this like a business not
a state agency
um and there's two reasons one is the
cost of marketing has gone up
by double digits
um the cost of air time as well as the
cost of production costs has gone and
put the cost of inflation uh I think I
get an estimate probably a month ago
that it was 16 increase in production
costs so just to produce an ad which
costs 100 000 now costs a hundred and
sixteen thousand
um also we are cognizant of the fact
that mass has now approved sports
betting for which we derive this year
probably 30 million dollars in
profitability which is three times more
than we anticipated and you know we like
that
and so we're trying to maintain that
level of competition as well as revenue
and so that's the reason behind it one
of the things you'll notice is when it
comes to 22 versus 23 if we didn't need
it we don't spend it yeah no maybe no
concern about that yeah no it would be
for us you know my colleague to my right
here is fanatical uh he treats your
money like you wish everyone did uh in
terms of spending it and defending it so
um it's just so that if we need to sort
of run an advertising campaign or
approach Massachusetts and try and get
back some customers we have the funds to
just said what I said thank you I mean
you've come to us session after session
and you come to us you don't ask us
really for anything because you do all
your own stuff
um I'm a little bit concerned about what
Massachusetts is doing as well do you
anticipate a large percentage of loss in
terms or you're making an effort to do
more advertising to compete what do you
think is going to happen
um it's the billion dollar question I
know I get that a lot but
um
I draw Solas in what happened with New
York and New Jersey New Jersey was live
for a number of years before New York
was and there was a suggestion that New
Jersey would fall off a cliff and it
didn't happen
so we we look at sports betting in two
different ways retail and mobile
so retail of the facilities in Hampton
and
um Dover and Manchester and soon to be
other states other parts of the state
I expect almost no loss there
when it comes to mobile
um
it's a good question
um I would expect double digits but not
much and certainly so some impact which
is reflected in our Revenue estimates
for the out years but not critical
absolutely not you know to the point of
being Terror
and my next question is what tricks do
you have up your sleeve
um one of the things we've pride
ourselves in greatly is we're number two
in the country per capita for sports
Revenue so it's New York one New
Hampshire's number two and then there's
a bunch of States way off the cliff
um in terms of money that goes to the
state to pay for State Services
um as you notice we didn't ask for
anything
nor did we submit anything I don't think
any there's many submissions I know that
Senator Lang has a bill for online
gaming which may make its way over to
you folks at some point uh that would be
the next iteration of gambling that
all right thank you uh charitable gaming
seems so we've expanded and what what's
your role in uh in that so in childhood
gambling
um that area is under the division of
Investigation compliance and enforcement
which is run by our chief compliance
officer in that regard we're very much a
referee and a regulator we're not an
operator and so we maintain
um licensing Authority as well as
regulatory authority over virtually
everything they do within the facility
so our Authority begins and ends at the
threshold and so
so no no so uh it's been an issue with
towns like Conway was an issue I was up
there last week uh Lebanon has raised
the issue
um there is revenue from it so it
depends on what areas charitable
gambling we're talking about under what
are called games of chance we derive a
certain percentage of the revenue
charity desire derives a certain
percentage and the operator does
under historic horse racing which has
been an issue recently
um the operator retains 75 of the
revenue
of the remaining 25
a third goes to the charity two-thirds
goes to the state so you're talking
approximately profitability to the state
and charitable gambling total an
estimate around say next year 16 or 17
million
between historic horse racing and as
well as games including historical yeah
I forgot about a story yeah that's okay
um so you expect that to grow I do I do
but you know as you can imagine we tend
to be conservative with our numbers
because one of the difficulties in our
job is if we give you a number you spend
it and then we have to go make it and so
a year from now you come back and say
why didn't you hit our number then it's
that's one of our one of our challenges
is I I don't know when a Warren
Ukrainian is going to raise gas prices
and lottery sales well for clear for the
equivalent it's it's difficult so we
tend to be on the moderately
conservative side of our estimates
stay on the charitable gambling for a
second yeah
our church is debating whether to
participate
and there's somebody got up and said
well they're changing the numbers
it used to be 35 to the charity and now
they're dropping it to 10 so I think
what they're talking about is that
historic racing correct okay so that did
change but yeah it's just what it's
being done in the in the facility has a
different take essentially okay that's
all thank you
yeah thank you could we get a chart
about where all these things fit in
absolutely you know just to get a little
picture of it because the charitable
sense has gone into it has gone a little
bit you know just it's just one more
Avenue to consider so a little picture
would help and then did you consider
selling mentholated tickets
[Laughter]
so we actually sold
um our head of products and sales This
brilliant woman and she came up with the
idea to sell bacon Center tickets
which no I was not we actually saw it
was scratching sniff bacon sent a ticket
it was called I love bacon and it was on
Good Morning America it was on CBS News
it was on it was on the it was national
news it was um yeah it's and I we went
through seven eight iterations of the
bacon smell all of which I tested my
I actually
um I don't know if you find this funny I
don't know if it's appropriate but I was
I was almost sued by PETA because it was
a big because I'd use bacon in a ticket
and I said it's just chemicals it's just
it's literally just a reaction of two
but uh so I literally paid a Peter's
takedown page for several days was us
and me about how we were offending pigs
thank you so I'm sorry I have to ask
this but when we were trying to get
gambling we couldn't get it failed
but now now the charitable gaming
casinos are coming up with where are
they coming up with these licenses how
did they how did they do that so as part
of the authorization of historic horse
racing there was a provision which
allowed facilities which which had had
games of chance charitable gaming
license as of a certain date to be
authorized to engage in charitable
gambling specifically store course
racing
as of at that date and they were the
only ones that are eligible until July
of 24. July 1 2024. it's in the HHR
enabling legislation I get you a copy it
if you want in terms of the language
um thank you that would be helpful yeah
and certainly there are
there were 12 communities around the
state all of which had had facilities
that were authorized
some hadn't been built yet but they've
been authorized they'd received the
approvals and they scattered the states
it's from Berlin to Hampton over to
Keene and and Nashua so it's kind of a
surprise for the local people all of a
sudden a casino shows up yeah I mean
certainly it's called a casino it's
called a casino for the obvious reasons
it's good marketing
um I often decide Casino was a term of
art it's like saying what's a bistro I
don't know they serve food they have
drinks nice tables and so for me it's
just what gambling is authorized by the
state and we regulate whatever
gambling's authorized by you folks we
didn't we didn't we don't we don't get
into Marketing in terms of truth of
advertising what they call themselves
thank you yeah
I appreciate if you could send me that
of course yeah let me um
thank you Mr chairman just a quick
follow-up to this
um I think I understand that you were
saying that the authorization right now
is for the 12 existing or authorized
historic horse racing facilities at the
time of the legislation was passed
button you mentioned July 2024 what
happened is then okay so it's actually
12 towns in some of the towns there are
multiple locations so that's what two I
want to make sure I get that clear
remember that's all
um so the law proposed and you folks
approved a moratorium of new facilities
until July 1 of 2024. there are several
bills flying around which would extend
that or make that permanent
um those for you to decide
um after that date new facilities can be
opened
the
thing is is that we approved rules
through jail car which restrict the type
of facilities that can be launched and
by that you mean
in order to be historic horse racing
Revenue you have to have so much of your
floor being table spaced and so much of
the floor so much of your Revenue be
derived from table games and that was a
couple of reasons one is to protect the
Charities because as of July 24
if an operator has to get up 45 of his
profit to the state and Charities for
tables and only 25 percent of its
revenue from machines if I'm a
businessman tables go away because
they're far more expensive to run
because you have to have people it's
expensive machines just electricity
which admittedly is more expensive it
used to be but you know it's still less
less expensive and so I wanted to make
sure that the Charities that get derive
all this money would get
their share and then some and so there's
a natural limit to what the expansion
can be but certainly as of July 24 there
can be new facilities under the existing
law okay so if obviously if the statutes
remain unchanged because whatever
changes changes but assuming no
legislative changes
in July 2024 we may see a growth in this
area because this current restrict
restricting statue has a Sunset date of
correct though I would suggest you as
somebody who does gambling for a living
candidly the market has a limit it's
just a quick any foreign market
um these machines while they've been
characterized as video Lottery terminals
slot machines they're not as popular not
as
they're just not as popular to Gamblers
as a casino machine would be uh and so
there's a natural limit to it I would
somewhere on 1500 Statewide mostly in
the South and so you're not going to
have a proliferation because the
Market's not going to support it these
things are very expensive to run are
regulations that govern the management
of these
it's it's a seven-figure investment just
in complying with our rules for getting
the building the cost the labor all
those things and so I would imagine
you're not going to see the
proliferation that folks would fear
I'm all free
[Laughter]
Mick thank you very much thank you Mr
committee and they said you want to
follow up any questions happy to answer
um uh going forward
thank you so much
tried
can I ask a procedure a question Vicky
if we can we
I just signed off on hb1
now that it's not once it's fully signed
off and it's in the House's hands can we
make changes to hb1 in this committee
can we recommend changes to one
absolutely that's what we're any of the
Motions that we do that I'll compile
will ultimately be our proposed
amendments to House Bill one and house
bill 2. so but I guess let me
does it have to go through two to get to
one or can we go directly to one no
they're separate bills so we amend so
for instance the classline error that
the Lottery Commission just stated on
the uh the what is it the responsible
gaming right uh Council so this
committee can make a vote to make that
change and then I would just compile
that and all the changes that I'm that
I'm making uh for now until we hit our
deadline so like that's something you
can do now we're still in work session
um if you wanted to do that to authorize
to approve that that requested change
we're going to receive one more change
he had talked about that Software System
uh they're going to give us details to
that which they didn't have with them
today so once we get that that'll be
another item that you could consider for
lottery as well
so we could take it up after the next
after
certainly anytime yeah we're in session
now uh until two and then police
standards is in at two o'clock so
anytime
get Harry back in here we could take a
this is a very uh this is about the
easiest thing the committee will do so
it's a good practice I guess for process
so but does it take to take a
kind of be a show of hands or does it
have to be yeah okay yeah I mean we can
the clerk can usually take a uh a vote
and just to show hands is fine and then
I'll all of those affirmative actions
that the committee takes I will compile
those with my changes right through okay
uh yeah foreign
yeah this is a technical correction
really
so yeah you can see the 250 000 per year
was it should just be in class 102 not
class 70. so that's the change they were
if you would say that one more time
what we're talking about is
taking a vote on an administrative
change in the
there's a technical correction here on
page 1211 of the governor's Budget on
accounting unit 8054 you can see that
there's 250 000 per year in class 70.
that should be in class 102 and the
Lottery Commission had asked that we
okay do you have a motion to that effect
move by Mary secretary by Joe all those
in favor please raise your hands
no yeah well we didn't need to do a roll
call on it we can do a show of hands but
I think you have to fill out a yeah
you're going to have to take my paper
I mean it's it's these are all just uh
recommendations I guess for me to put
together your final vote on
recommendation on all of your
recommendations I'll be at the end okay
so we don't so I mean it's it's up to
the clerk if he wants to take notes of
these small uh motions as they're going
along
and I will say as we get into some of
the other agencies here we're going to
get more technical requests to make so
some keying errors may be occurred
they've noticed things that once the
governor's budget came out oh that's the
wrong class line or the wrong source of
funds so as we get those it helps me if
we can approve those quickly because
then I can do the keying in the budget
system and the budget entry uh you know
as I'm going along rather than
everything at the end
okay well I guess we're done until two
o'clock
when police stand
is this is this a budget where you know
we need to wait or is it something that
we are ready to
start Nick he's got one of the writings
exactly uh Salesforce software oh yeah
yeah well you know that's why I nailed I
went to uh
I play I played online I couldn't
and well what happened I had my debit
card and I use that to you know
and then Hardware pump I'll actually use
my voicemail and then then I send they
said well send a check in so I said you
hey it's two o'clock Apple time
with New Hampshire police standard and
and the floor is yours
thank you Mr chair uh thank you all
for the record my name is John skip I'm
the director of New Hampshire police
standards and training and our mission
is to shape strengthen and sustain the
competency and professionalism of New
Hampshire law enforcement in service to
the police standards and training
Council regulates the hiring educational
and certification standards for all
police officers State Corrections
Officers and probation parole officers
in the state of New Hampshire
we operate the New Hampshire Police
Academy which all Municipal Police
County Sheriff deputies and state
troopers conservation officers really
anyone who is a certified law
enforcement officer in the state of New
Hampshire must attend
in order to become certified as a
full-time police officer
we also operate the part-time officer of
basic training class that all part-time
police officers must complete to obtain
their part-time certification as well as
the New Hampshire Corrections Academy
that all state level Corrections
Officers must attend in order to obtain
their certification
we also provide specialized Advanced and
in-service refresher training to our at
our facility in Concord and regionally
around the state to assist officers in
completing the annual requirements to
maintain their certification
as part of our responsibility for
regulating over 4 000 certified officers
in the state
we convene and rule on disciplinary
hearings
that may suspend or Revolt the
certification of officers that have
violated Council rules or committed a
crime
or an act of moral turpitude
we are an independent executive branch
agency
now governed by 17 member Council
we are not affiliated with any other law
enforcement or prosecutorial agency in
the state thereby avoiding potential
conflicts of interest with our
regulatory function and decertification
duties
we provide services with 24 full-time
and six part-time positions which
includes sworn staff administrative and
maintenance employees
our staff has assisted by adjunct
instructors most of whom are unpaid
volunteers and a small number of
contracted instructors
we operate a 77 000 square foot training
facility located on 20.87 Acres of
grounds across from nhti's Concords
with regard to uh the efficiency budget
request Das had provided our agency with
Target allocations from the governor's
office of no more than a three percent
increase in FY 24 and zero percent
increase in fy25 our submitted
efficiency budget request meets those
requirements
are adjusted authorized budget for FY 23
is currently 5 million six two zero zero
three zero
5788 631 represents a three percent
increase above the FY 23 adjusted
and our FY 25 request of five seven
eight eight six three one represents a
zero percent increase
for fiscal year 24.
there are a number of new programs that
our agency has taken on it's important
to note that these new responsibilities
have come in to our purview since the
last budget cycle
these new responsibilities are the
result of the 2022 legislation
through administrative rule changes
based on recommendations made by the
governor's law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency commission and through
realignment of responsibilities between
state agencies
Senate Bill 376
in the 2022 session to sign police
standards and training with providing
Crisis Intervention training to New
Hampshire Law Enforcement Officers with
the target of having at least one
officer from every law enforcement
agency in the state trained
executive order
2022-06 assigned police standards and
training with the responsibility of
overseeing the Statewide accreditation
program for law enforcement agencies
this program is not funded Beyond a doj
grant that will expire at the end of
fiscal year 2023.
House Bill 1682
during the 2022 session established the
law enforcement conduct Review Committee
under police standards and training
this committee will be responsible for
overseeing and reviewing all
investigations regarding allegations of
through executive order
2020-19 and administrative rule change
has now been amended to increase the
number of annual in-service training
hours for all certified Law Enforcement
Officers as a condition of their
continued certification from eight hours
annually increasing incrementally to 24
hours of annual training by 2025.
police standards and training has
assumed primary responsibility for
overseeing and delivering all active
shooter alert training
which initially sat with the Department
of Homeland Security and Emergency
Management
and that change was done so as to Define
training areas of responsibility more
clearly
with regard to our additional price
prioritized needs
they include two full-time positions to
assist with some of these new
responsibilities
one of the requests is is a program
specialist three
with the hope that they will be able to
manage the new programs given to us
during FY 23 to include active shooter
alert training
and Statewide accreditation for law
as dictated under executive order
2022-06
the second full-time position is for a
training development manager
which is critically needed to develop
online training content for law
enforcement agencies
through the liac recommendations and
executive order
2020-19 annual in-service training
requirements were increased from 8 to 24
hours
Additionally the department of
I.T here in New Hampshire has requested
an additional
16998 in fy24 and
18145 in fiscal year 25 for shared
course costs uh increases in software
costs support and consulting services
and Dot doit increases for additional
funded positions
our total agency budget request as
recommended by the governor for fy24
is
five million nine hundred sixty four
thousand four hundred forty two which is
a 5.8 percent increase over FY 23
and six thousand
sorry six million forty eight thousand
349 in fiscal year 25 which is a 1.4
percent increase over FY 24.
our proposed FY 2425 budget reflects
compliance with Target allocations set
forth by Das while attempting to
appropriately resource our current
obligations of providing contemporary
recruit training to newly hired officers
creating and delivering in-service
training regulating and monitoring
compliance with Professional Standards
as well as preparing to meet the number
of new obligations as outlined above
like to take this opportunity to thank
all of you for listening to our
presentation and I stand ready to answer
any questions that anyone might have
I have one question on uh
the program is not funded Beyond doj
grant that will expire at the end of 23.
it's one of the hires that you're
talking about going to do with that
which is not being funded anymore
uh thank you very much for that question
and it's an excellent segue for and the
one ask that we have that's beyond what
I've submitted well I gave you the
softball thank you yeah
um that uh that doj Grant was to
establish a state level accreditation
program that is voluntary in nature
uh we had hopes of using the doj grant
to fund a contracted position who could
oversee the program
uh the uh the person that is mentioned
in my presentation would be more of a
Administrative Assistant uh position to
help with uh the the volume of calls and
paperwork and things like that are going
to have to be spoken to
um
the the ask
would be for consideration of an
additional seventy five thousand dollars
per fiscal year
to help us really strongly establish
this accreditation program which is
brand new here in the state of New
Hampshire
um we really want this to be successful
and our initial Hope was to try to have
the the accreditation program
self-funded
through uh application fees uh but I I
just want to make sure that fiscally
we're able to uh kind of close the deal
as we roll this program out and I don't
know that we're going to generate enough
money uh coming back in
to help offset the cost of a contractor
to oversee our program
and that would be the 75 would be in
addition to the presentation that I just
made
Mary thank you
um Mr chair and thank you for your
presentation
um
when last you were here
um we had just finished the leak and
there were so many recommendations and
you had a lot of work to do readjusting
your curriculum and making sure
everybody was prepared to do everything
that
the world has changed and that
commission had a lot of work for you how
did all that turn out
thank you so much for that question and
thank you for uh
thank you for your interest too that uh
candidly there was a heavy lift yes it
was a big big lift uh I am so fortunate
that uh I am surrounded by people at
police stands in training that really
make me very successful because they do
all the heavy lifting uh we were able to
accomplish about 90 of what liak was
asking us to do we have a couple of
small pieces that are still uh being
worked on uh but my staff uh really uh
did a phenomenal job and uh created a
tremendous amount of content that was
necessary we realigned uh the curriculum
we are looking towards the future in
terms of making sure that New Hampshire
is setting the bar for training of law
enforcement officers uh not just you
know in New England but across the
country and we're very excited we we
take that challenge on uh very excited
I live in Manchester and we have a
fabulous police chief he's she's the
best but we also really have a hard time
recruiting police officers it's not a
job people want to do anymore
um what what can we do or what I are we
doing as a state to um even your own
Troopers it's it's hard to get people
who who are willing to get out there uh
there are more guns out there there's
more risk uh people don't know when they
stop somebody if it's going to be
something more than they anticipated so
what can we it's such a critical thing
how can we help this or what what can we
do
thank you for that question this uh I
had the occasion to be in Washington DC
uh this last weekend
and uh I'm part of a project with the
Department of Justice and the Bureau of
Justice assistance to help uh create a
nationwide constitutional policing
curriculum that allowed me an
opportunity to sit down and talk with
some of my my peers from across the
country
what we are seeing here in New Hampshire
is
is candidly not nearly as bad as what
other parts of the country are seeing
with regard to Recruitment and Retention
issues
uh nonetheless New Hampshire's very much
in that mix we're we're suffering
from those problems as well
the sad truth is that where we are not
getting people
uh that that are really Forward Thinking
and and uh could really bring some some
tremendous change to our industry
because they don't want to
face uh the daunting task of being a
police officer it is it is a challenge
that is uh many people just don't want
anything to do with now
there's a general feeling that
um
there's really no support uh from the
communities that they serve
there's probably some concern that
they're not supported by their own
agencies
um they're afraid that they're going to
have to make a decision that they will
be vilified for later on
even though it's a hundred percent
correct decision
uh
I've been in law enforcement for almost
40 years now and I I have never seen it
like this before ever
uh it is
um
I don't believe it's a problem that's
going away anytime soon
we only need to look here in New
Hampshire where you know we're looking
at Staffing deficits that are crushing
uh Department of Corrections crushing
New Hampshire State Police crushing
right now
um I don't know the answer we we
collectively in our business have done
everything we can
to try to
recruit people uh actively going out
there and recruiting like I've never
seen before in our business and I just I
don't know what that answer is
thank you Mr chair and thank you for you
know answering questions and frankly for
the work you do it's really tough
I I would State on the record that I
don't think that the concern for safety
in terms of coming to New Hampshire to
be a police officer is a big concern we
are either the safest or the second
safest state in the country overall
police work is still dangerous you know
but relative to other states it
shouldn't really be a big deal and also
you know I'm from Windham and God knows
we support our police department and yet
we cannot find we have an open position
we haven't been able to file for a while
you were mentioning concerns about you
know being vilified if you make a bad
decision
I remember reading and again this is not
about New Hampshire police it's just
general knowledge I remember reading
that at some point the training was
you know rather aggressive in how they
should handle situations and now we are
adjusting the training to focus more on
de-escalating and trying to
is that something that we need to do you
know continuing down on that path with
that help in the longer term means some
of those pressures do you think that's
part of the solution and seriously what
can we do to help in creating whatever
regulatory framework or anything that
would make it possible for the agency to
you know find the right people who do
the right job I mean at the end of the
day we all need Public Safety and you
know what what can we do I'm you know
I'm not an expert on those
thank you sir for that question I I I
wish I had that answer I don't know
um there's there's a lot of theories out
there these are not my positions I'll
just relate to you what I have heard you
know from my peers uh there is uh you
know the question of of uh you know
should police officers be uh more
heavily compensated right if we want to
really professionalize do they need more
money
uh
better equipment uh better connection to
the community
um
you know it when you're faced with a job
that requires you to work uh
nights weekends and holidays versus I
can take a job in Boston working for a
private firm and make make better money
and nobody's going to try and hurt me
and I do agree with you this is a very
safe place to work as a police officer I
I absolutely agree with you
uh I just don't know that answer and I I
wish I did and that and this is a
question that is asked across the
country what can we do to
to recruit people uh really smart uh
forward-thinking people uh who are going
to stay in the business for a long time
seriously I would appreciate you know if
something comes to mind feel free to
reach out to you know me or anybody else
proactively and see again if a strategy
comes up that you know we could
Implement from a policy I know now we're
talking budget but obviously the budget
issues are gonna be influenced by
policies so you know please stay you
know let us know absolutely thank you
sir
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
handstrong leadership position in the
state and I recall it one of our recent
Town budget hearings he spoke about the
fact that many of the new police academy
uh like trainees who make it through
their program
either fail the written exam or don't
pass the background check
um so I'm wondering you know from
hearing that description there must be
some sort of cost savings to be had from
running the background check prior to
the Academy training and sitting for the
exam so that we're not losing someone
after investing that important
um resource into you know studying these
folks up and getting them ready to go
you know if we could save money on the
front end by not putting them through
their program if we already know they're
going to fail the test uh the background
check right
so uh I've had the distinct pleasure of
thank you for the question I've had the
distinct pleasure for who would uh Chief
Dennis he's a great guy and a really
strong police leader here in New
Hampshire in fact uh the recruit will
not attend the academy until they pass a
full background check to include a
psychological exam a medical exam a
polygraph exam and uh and that full
background where we we talked to past
employers and and family members and
just really make sure that they're not
bringing any kind of you know bad habits
or criminal Behavior or anything like
that uh so no they they will not attend
the academy until that check is done for
that very reason yeah the unfortunate
truth is that at a base level
uh Hanover PD will spend a lot of money
on vetting that particular candidate
then they may have spent over time on
the background investigator put them
through a medical test which costs money
and a psych test and then all of a
sudden something pops in their
background
and and you know Hanover PD is into that
that particular candidate for you know
maybe a thousand dollars and then they
have to start again so it it is
um
it is frustrating I will tell you that
New Hampshire's hiring standards have
not changed
and as as long as I am
where I'm at I I would strongly urge no
changes to our hiring standards
because when you do see hiring standards
lessened
that thousand dollars that Hanover spent
is is Pennies on dollars compared to
what what could happen you know by
hiring somebody who should not be given
this privilege to be a law enforcement
officer
thank you there was a time when you were
getting older candidates going through
are there still older people who are you
know maybe perhaps a retired military
um do you still get that sort of a
candidate
uh thank you for the question yes we do
and um it's interesting not only do we
get uh retired uh folks from the
military who uh candidly do very very
well in the academy setting and have
great careers uh we're actually seeing
uh older adults who may have owned their
own business or worked in uh you know
Private Industry for for a long period
of time and then had this calling for
public service and and so they do step
up and and it is my opinion that the uh
the ex the life experience that those
folks bring to the table is is
phenomenal and it makes them great
officers because they they already have
the interpersonal skills to be very
successful
um when I was reading this or you were
reading it to us
um about SB 367
um training Law Enforcement Officers
Target of having at least one officer
from every law enforcement agency in the
state train I was either this is I'm
trying to
how did you Define law enforcement
agency I'm either thinking this is too
many people are not enough people and
what brought to mind is that you know
Newcastle probably does not need one if
we're you know if you're defining that
as a law enforcement agency so what do
you mean by law enforcement agency
uh thank you for that question yeah
every single Police Department uh that's
that's what the target is and um that uh
that Target was set by the senator that
had uh sponsored this bill uh that was
his vision and
um ultimately was signed into law I am
very familiar with uh Newcastle I was a
rye police officer for 12 years so we
used to meet at Floyd's Corner a lot and
thank you Mr chairman I was just
recalling that
um
the first day you had to shut everything
down and it looks like you held up
pretty well
hahaha
you you are you are correct sir thank
you uh my very first official uh act as
the Director of New Hampshire law
enforcement standards and training was
to shut the building down and uh I
introduced myself to the class
I'm the new guy you have 15 minutes to
go upstairs and get all your stuff and
get out of here you're gonna go back to
where you came from uh yes a little
follow-up um
there was one example that happened
um
to prove that you know all New Hampshire
law enforcement has the same training
and I'm glad to see that I'm glad to
have that and the one example to prove
that how valuable that was was that
disaster down in Texas where they had
hundreds of law enforcement people are
different all under different leadership
and
got nowhere it was just to so I'm just I
just want to thank you for having having
what we have here in New Hampshire have
all our law enforcement have the same
training
thank you sir and thank all of you for
the for that support we are the Envy of
uh I ran a police academy down in
Massachusetts they Envy New Hampshire
because of the way we do business as
does a lot of states and we're very very
number of annual in-service training
hours from 8 to 24 hours do you have
funding for that where is that extra
funding coming from how do you manage
that thank you for that question uh this
budget as proposed is is going to help
us uh do that I think one of the things
that we need to do at the police academy
is to leverage online training uh
leveraging online training will be able
to spread our resources uh in a way
where we can reach more officers and
also reduce the costs associated with
overtime and backfill
versus sending people to a face-to-face
class there are some classes that they
do need to be face to face it is what it
is we tried uh
doing some pistol qualifications online
it didn't go no that's not sure
uh but so you know certainly we we do
have to um have some face-to-face
classes uh but we really do need to
leverage our online learning uh system
and we do have a online learning system
in place uh we just have to build
content and building content online
about an hour of content about 100 hours
worth of behind the scene work uh to do
it correctly right so uh but thank you
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted an
observation at one point the state
police came in and gave us a map showing
all the towns that they are responsible
for because they have less than
1200 or 13 some number of population
still many of these will have a police
chief
who's there 30 40 hours a week rest the
time the state police have the
responsibility for that town so when
they have this one person many times it
is not a certain certificated person
which is why this law was passed because
okay it's your turn you're the chief
some of these things you never know in a
small town so that's I think what
they're getting at rather than saying
there's a lot of
non-qualified police Chiefs around this
or policemen around it's just this this
small town and I remember one near me
that you know they were kind of contract
him with the sheriff or
was It was kind of in the corner of the
State Police didn't have more trouble
getting there so it is a surprise
in some places one time around me in
Rockingham County there were three
retired policemen who were Chiefs
so they got 30 hours a week but one of
them told me he said me and two other
officers saved the town a hundred
thousand dollars because we're working
part-time and not and the town doesn't
have to make that 20-some percent
contribution to the retirement system so
there's a lot of things going on that we
may not be familiar with but at least
we're usually getting a 20 plus year
experienced guy that's running a
thank you Mr chairman I'm looking at um
two of your admin of your organizational
units the administration and standards
and also the law enforcement training in
the line 50 personal service temporary
appointed
both of them have quite a big bump
between 22 and 23
and the first one also continues to
increase in 24 and 25. any um you know
color on what's going on there I mean
you know 22 to 23 is one thing and then
one of them grows more from 23 through
the 24 25.
uh thank you for the question sir could
I ask just uh
what page are you referring to on the
state budget yes page 1213 yes and then
also page 12
14 but let's just focus on the 12 13
about middle of the page line 50 050
personal service stamp appointed the
oh sorry my bad I marked the wrong line
that's why you need to use a piece of
paper I'll get a ruler you and I both
sir
um the uh it's going from 204 to 332 and
then 382 and 402. yes uh I I cannot
speak directly to why those increases
happen uh those
um benefits oh I'm sorry I'm going to
for the record my name is Max Schultz
I'm a major with police standard
training so the the uh prioritized needs
budget added two additional full-time
positions and that would be under this
8980 Administration and standards
account I believe that's why you're
seeing an increase in I got it and to be
fairy already whispered that to me so I
thank you Mr chair that reminds me
um in your
request to the governor for your budget
what didn't you get that you asked for
thank you for that question uh the the
governor was very supportive of the two
uh prioritized needs that we put forth
and and uh his office uh supported both
of those requests
I
we again I I would have asked for that
other 75 000 per budget year
but uh working with the accreditation
commission and trying to work with doj
and the Federal Grant
by the time we realized that we're
probably just going to need that seed
money uh it was this had already been
submitted
just to clarify so I did hand out the
fiscal item that uh is actually on the
agenda for tomorrow's fiscal so this is
an accept and expend for the police
standards and training Council for
fiscal 23 of 75 000 of uh pass-through
grant money through the Department of
Justice
what uh director skip is referring to is
needing a continuation of this program
for fiscal 24 and 25 and I think we
would just want to clarify if there's an
expectation that Grant funds would be
available or if you would be asking for
General funds during the the next two
years just to make sure that that's
clear
uh thank you sir to allow for
clarification that would be
um we are going to seek
any kind of grant funding that we we can
but uh we would be asking for uh general
foreign
I I just want to thank everyone again
for
um the ability to come here and talk
with you and and uh thank you for your
questions and and certainly uh we stand
ready uh to answer any question anybody
might have I'm I'm happy to take a phone
call or an email if if that uh that
needs to happen stand ready to help we
certainly thank you for keeping New
Hampshire safe
oh thank you Mr chairman
um when did what's the date of the uh
that the uh or the police station
Training Academy when was that uh first
I see 71 but what do you know when
exactly because I I finished in June of
71 and I think I was uh my partner was
one of the first
Academy graduates uh Gene Reed which I
don't know if you keep track of that but
we we do we we have uh the graduation
rolls all the way back to the very
beginning so did you go to were you at
peas no I was I was on the Farmington PD
okay and I I and I was in uniform you
know I was a cop sure I said you know I
might as well go back in the service and
that's what I did but my partner uh I
actually I wanted to trust the trust
funds in the town now okay in fact we
got a meeting tonight and his daughter
is on the trustees which you know kind
of I I didn't realize that she was you
know that the relationship
but then I'm getting that old it was it
must have been after June because I I
wasn't aware that uh police standing in
training was must have been be informed
at that time you're exactly correct we
were we were uh constituted in 1971
through Governor's order and um
uh we just we just uh celebrated our
well 51st birthday right
I that I do not know but um I I know
exactly where the documents are that
we'll we'll answer that and I'm I will
so I am the sixth
yeah I am the sixth
there's let's hope right
hahaha
I just I just wanted to add that uh my
training was go out and use common sense
that was it and that was it was good
advice matter of fact Carl Worcester you
might have heard well he was the chief
at the time and uh you know that was it
was interesting
but but we and and to cover what uh
State Police they were very very helpful
in uh you know because you got training
from listening to them and even though
he was a rookie Ronnie Callaway I'm sure
you've heard of him yep uh there was a
great uh it was it was a great
experience it was a thankless experience
but it was a great experience yes well
it's always good when the boss gives you
a gun and a badge and and it throws you
the keys and says hey don't cause any
problems out there that was my
introduction she didn't give me a gun he
gave me the badge I think I still have
it somewhere
he wanted it back but I didn't give it
back good for you you deserve it
okay thank you for coming thank you so
much
foreign
we've said this before the the heavy
workload for this division will be a
highway you know education
Transportation so these smaller agencies
are the simpler budgets if you complete
them now it's just less to worry about
later
I would hold off on lottery only because
he's going to come back with that
million dollar request so we just need
to wait for that but once once that does
come through
um we'll add a future work session you
could do that for sure